Good morning. Hi. Jinks, buy me a Coke. Do you drink Coke? Do you even know what a Coke is? No, I don't. And what is that? Hang on a second.
早上好。嗨。吉克斯，给我买瓶可口可乐。你喝可乐吗？你甚至知道可乐是什么吗？不，我不知道。那是什么？等一下。
Jinks, buy me a Coke? You never heard Jinks, buy me a Coke? When you say the same thing, you go, Jinks, buy me a Coke. I've never heard buy me a Coke. Is that a Chicago thing maybe? I don't know. I think it's a universal American thing.
吉克斯，给我买瓶可口可乐？你从来没听过“吉克斯，给我买瓶可口可乐”吗？当你俩同时说出一样的话时，你就会说，吉克斯，给我买瓶可口可乐。我从来没听过买可乐这说法。难道这是芝加哥那边的习惯？我不知道。我觉得这是全美通用的说法。
No, I've been living in America for quite some time, and I've worked for Universal. Oh, that's right. And neither of those instances did I hear that phrase. Welcome to a new smart list. Smart. Hey, Sean. Sean, you got up a little early today and did your hair, huh?
不，我在美国住了挺长时间了，我还为环球影业工作过。哦，对哦。而且这两次经历中我都从没听过这个短语。欢迎收听全新的《聪明糊涂账》。聪明。嘿，肖恩。肖恩，你今天起得有点早，还弄了头发哈？
Well, this is left over from last night. But I got it. Did you sleep in a bonnet? No. You know my daughters? My daughter's both sleep in bonnets now, so their hair wakes up nice and fresh. Really? Yeah.
哦，这是昨晚留到现在的。不过我弄好了。你睡觉时戴着软帽吗？没有。你认识我女儿吗？我两个女儿现在睡觉都戴着软帽，这样她们醒来时头发又好看又清爽。真的吗？对。
Yeah, I don't think. It's like silky satin bonnets. Look at yours. Like a night shirt and a bonnet when they walk around with a candle. The candle. The candle. Like Scrooge. Yeah.
对，我不觉得。就像丝绸缎面的软帽。看看你们的。就像穿着睡衣戴着软帽，手里还拿着蜡烛走来走去的人。蜡烛。蜡烛。就像《圣诞欢歌》里的斯克鲁奇。对。
Oh. Oh, Jesus. Oh, he is ill. Yeah, I'm fucking sick still. Yeah. How about I got two colds in two weeks? I know. I can't believe back.
哦。哦，天哪。哦，他病得不轻。对，我他妈的还是病得很重。对。我怎么两周内感冒了两次？我知道。真不敢相信又来了。
I've got Theraflu going right now. I did that same thing, J.B., we were talking about yesterday. I had three colds since October, and they just went back to back to back. It's like, insane. Yeah. Why am I such a bitch when I'm sick? Are you on the mend? Yeah, but I still coughing and I'm grouchy and draggy and spoky.
我正在喝泰诺呢。我昨天也经历了同样的事，JB，我们刚刚还在说呢。我从十月开始已经感冒三次了，而且是一场接一场。简直太疯狂了。对。为什么我生病的时候脾气这么臭？你在康复中吗？对，但我还在咳嗽，又暴躁、又疲惫、又虚弱。
Can Sean bring you something? Yes, I did offer... No, he... I get it. I know who's a caretaker here. Oh, how dare you? He did offer twice yesterday. I know.
肖恩能给你带点什么吗？对，我确实主动提出过……不，他……我懂。我知道谁才是这里的护工。哦，你怎么敢这么说！他昨天确实主动问了两次。我知道。
Such an angel. Well, I mean, do you really want me to? Well, no, I haven't asked you for anything yet, but I'm good. I'm all right. If you want something, Nick is happy to bring something over for sure. My assistant. Will, where are you? Are you in L.A.?
真是个小天使。好吧，我是说，你真的想让我去吗？好吧，不，我还没向你索取任何东西，但我很好。我没事。如果你想要什么，尼克很乐意帮你带过来。我的助理。威尔，你在哪？你在洛杉矶吗？
I'm home. I'm in L.A. Yeah, it's so nice. Wait, so you're closer to me than Sean is, so you can bring me something. I would love to... I would love to. And if I'm just looking at my calendar now, I would love to.
我在家。我在洛杉矶。对，太好了。等等，所以你离我比肖恩近，所以你可以给我带点东西。我很乐意……我很乐意。如果我正看着我的日程表的话，我很乐意。
You're looking for sleeves for your shirt? Today? Yeah. I know. Says me, listen, at least I'm wearing just because it's like gym wear. You know what I mean?
你在给你的衬衫找袖子吗？今天？是的。我知道。我说，听着，至少我穿着……这只是因为像是健身服。你知道我的意思吗？
I'm not like pulling a throw. Are you guys bitches when you're sick? Yes. Yeah, I'm the worst. All dudes are. All dudes are. I'm the worst.
我可不是在瞎胡闹。你们生病的时候脾气也很差吗？对。对，我是最差的。所有男人都是。所有男人都是。我是最差的。
I don't know. I think some guys can just kind of push through it. No. Me, I like cancel everything. I'm surprised I didn't get. Well, I know why I didn't cancel this.
我不知道。我觉得有些男的就能硬扛过去。不。我嘛，我会取消所有的行程。我很惊讶我居然没有……好吧，我知道我为什么没有取消这个。
Yeah. I know I didn't cancel this. This has been canceled before. I know you, you, I know I ran into somebody on the weekend, J.B. And, sorry, I'm hearing less gain from Rob for me. Okay, got you. Loud and clear, Rob. Thank you.
对。我知道我为什么没有取消这个。这节目以前也被取消过。我认识你，你，我知道我周末碰到了某个人，JB。而且，抱歉，我觉得罗伯传给我的声音变小了。好的，明白了。听得清清楚楚，罗伯。谢谢你。
Jesus. Wait, did he give you a side text to lower your gain? Yeah, he did. He's like, so rude. Too much of you. And you know what I mean? Anyway, somebody I ran into this weekend said you were supposed to do something and that you had to cancel because you were sick.
天哪。等等，他给你发了私信让你把音量调小？对，他发了。他语气好粗鲁。你的声音太大了。你知道我的意思吗？不管怎样，我这周末碰到的一个人说，你本该做点什么，但因为生病不得不取消了。
That probably would have been me. Yeah, I was supposed to go to a party with Shawnee. Yeah. And what else? Oh, I was supposed to do some frickin' press thingy, and I couldn't. It was a press thing. And Amanda and Frannie were in New York having fun. And me and Maple, Maple, she's the fucking dirty carrier that gave me this cold.
那个人大概是我吧。对，我本来要和肖妮一起去参加一个派对。对。还有什么？哦，我本该做什么鬼采访活动的，结果去不了。是个采访活动。而阿曼达和弗兰妮当时在纽约玩得很开心。我和梅普尔，梅普尔，她就是那个传染给我这场感冒的该死的脏东西。
I love when people get into, I love when people start to try to do, like, who they got the cold from. And it's their fault. just get it from, you know what I mean? I know, but it's, it's her. I had just gotten over COVID. I was weak. Remind us how old maple is again? I was supposed to be babysitting and she's, you know what?
我喜欢看人们开始，我喜欢看人们开始试图找出他们究竟是从谁那里染上感冒的。这都是他们的错。就是从……你知道我的意思吗？我懂，但这就是她。我才刚从新冠中恢复过来。我很虚弱。提醒我们一下梅普尔几岁了？我本来应该当保姆的，而她，你知道吗？
I had to test her temperature by, do you guys do this? You put your lips on the forehead. You put your lips on the forehead of someone to find out if they're running a fever or not because your lips will tell you. You can't put your hand against it because your hand is hot or cold, but whatever. You mean your lips. Yeah, if you rest your lips. Before thermometers, for sure, that's what we did.
我不得不通过这种方式来测她的体温，你们也这样吗？你把嘴唇贴在别人的额头上。你把嘴唇贴在某个人的额头上，来看看他们有没有发烧，因为你的嘴唇能感觉出来。你不能把手贴上去，因为你的手时热时冷，但不管怎样。你是说用嘴唇。对，如果你把嘴唇贴上去。在有温度计之前，我们肯定都是这么做的。
But for sure. And I think I got it by doing that, putting lips against her sweaty. No, you can't get it from that. How do you get it? You probably, she sneezed on her hand or something. She touched the surface and you touched the surface right after. You just didn't know. Who knows? You both got it from somewhere else.
那是肯定的。而且我觉得我就是这么被传染的，把嘴唇贴在她那流汗的……不，你不会通过那个被传染的。那你怎么被传染的？你可能……她打喷嚏打在手上了什么的。她摸了一个表面，然后你紧接着也摸了那个表面。你只是不知道罢了。谁知道呢？你们俩都是从别的地方沾上的。
I mean, what is she going to start to do? What are you going to sue the person you got? No, I know. I know. I know. Remember that during COVID? Everyone was like, who do you think they got it from? I know.
我是说，她打算怎么做？难道你要起诉把感冒传染给你的人吗？不，我懂。我懂。我懂。还记得新冠期间吗？每个人都问：你觉得他们是从谁那儿染上的？我知道。
Yeah, yeah. Who do you think? I know. Yeah. Anyway. I like it's their fault. Anyway. Anyway, look, Jay, you have 50 minutes
对，对。你觉得呢？我知道。对。不管怎样。就像是别人的错一样。不管怎样。不管怎样，听着，杰伊，你还有50分钟
before you can go back to sleep. All right. Hey, I think maybe we should move tomorrow's thing to the Zoom. I don't know if I can make it to that lunch. Oh, what do you think about that? What do you think? Oh, yeah.
才能回去睡觉。好吧。嘿，我觉得也许我们应该把明天的活动改到Zoom上。我不知道我能不能去参加那个午宴。哦，你觉得怎么样？你觉得呢？哦，对。
What do you think? Yeah, we can do that. Yeah, all right. I love it. I'd love to not see you tomorrow, to be honest, if you are still ill. Yeah, see, no one wants to get sick. No.
你觉得呢？对，我们可以那样做。好，太好了。说实话，如果你还在生病的话，我宁愿明天不见你。对，看吧，没人想生病。不。
All right, here we go. I'm going to fucking pull up my bootstraps for this one, because this is, listen. Can I just say this for your, Can I just say for your guest, again, I want to reiterate, because you are such a baby. And the fact, no, I'm going to say a baby. And the fact that you did do this is a real sign of respect to the guest,
好吧，开始吧。我得为这次采访振作起来，因为，听着。我能为你的……我能为你的嘉宾说句话吗？再次重申，因为你真是个巨婴。而且事实上，不，我要说这就是个巨婴。你居然能做到这一点，对嘉宾来说真是一种极大的尊重，
because knowing you and knowing how selfish you are, this is remarkable that you were able to sort of. This is a big deal for me. It's a big deal. I know this person, you must. You must. A tiny bit, but I want to know her more. Our guest today, this is the second youngest actress ever to win an Oscar.
因为了解你以及你有多自私，你能做到这一步真的很了不起。这对我来说是件大事。是件大事。我认识这个人，你必须得认识。你必须得认识。稍微了解一点，但我想更多地了解她。我们今天的嘉宾，这是有史以来获得奥斯卡奖第二年轻的女演员，
and the youngest person ever to be nominated three times. She knows how to act, but it's not because she went to some fancy drama school. She's self-taught. She also knows about world issues and is a fierce advocate for the less fortunate, but not because she went to some fancy live arts college. She's self-educated. She's glamorous, but she's not a diva. She's a major movie star, but she keeps it real, yo.
也是有史以来获得三次提名的最年轻的人。她懂得如何演戏，但这并不是因为她上了什么昂贵的戏剧学校。她是自学成才的。她还了解世界大事，是弱势群体的坚定倡导者，但这也不是因为她上了什么fancy的文理学院。她是自我教育的。她很有魅力，但一点也不大牌。她是个超级电影明星，但她为人真实，老兄。
And she has enormous wealth, but she still lives in her first car with her husband and two toddlers. Let's find out how she does it all, guys. Please welcome Ms. Jennifer Schrader Lawrence Maroni. I don't live in my car. You too live in your car. Living in your car. Are you referring to this TikTok? I've seen it.
她拥有巨额财富，但她依然和丈夫以及两个幼儿住在她的第一辆车里。让我们看看她是怎么这一切都兼顾的，各位。请欢迎珍妮弗·施雷德·劳伦斯·马罗尼女士。我不住在车里。你们俩都住在车里。住在车里。你是说这个TikTok视频吗？我看过。
Oh, no. Really? Oh, there's a TikTok that... Where you're living in your car? That my friend's nanny was like... It's like, Jennifer Lawrence, no matter how much wealth she has. She's never moved out of her first house. And she still drives her like the same car, but the car is like an old Buick.
哦，没有。真的吗？哦，有一个TikTok视频说……你住在车里？我朋友的保姆说……就像是，珍妮弗·劳伦斯不管她有多少财富。她从来没有搬出过她的第一栋房子。她开的还是同一辆车，但那车就像是一辆旧别克。
Will's already trying to pull it up. I don't have TikTok. I'm not. I was putting my thing on Do Not Service. Hi, guys. Hi. I listened to this podcast. I'm really excited to be honest.
威尔已经开始在搜了。我没有TikTok。我没有。我刚才在把手机调到“请勿打扰”。嗨，大家好。嗨。我听了这个播客。说实话我很激动。
Do you really? So, dude, she was supposed to be, she was my guest for the bowl. Yes. Yes. I know. I found out. How excited were you, Jennifer? To get the canceled.
真的吗？所以，老兄，她本来应该是，她是我在露天剧场的嘉宾。对。对。我知道。我发现了。你当时有多激动，珍妮弗？得知活动取消的时候。
When it got canceled. Was that just like the greatest call ever? For, I mean, for a person like me who likes to sit at home all day, when the rain came in. Yeah. You know, it felt like a blessing. Sure. Yeah. But I don't know if I go that.
当它取消的时候。那是不是感觉就像是有史以来最棒的电话？对于，我是说，对于像我这样喜欢整天呆在家里的人来说，当下雨的时候。对。你知道，感觉就像是一种祝福。确实。对。但我不知道我是不是会那样。
But I have, yeah, it seems like God was shining down. Yeah. Just the smartless cast and me. It would have been nice to be out there. How fun to be out there at the bowl. Would you guys, you guys wouldn't get stage, well, you guys do this in front of audiences a lot. So you're used to. I would have been nervous.
但我有，是的，感觉就像上帝在保佑。对。只有聪明糊涂账的主持人和我。能去那儿挺好的。在露天剧场演出一定很有趣。你们会，你们不会怯场……好吧，你们经常在观众面前表演。所以你们习惯了。我会紧张的。
I would have been nervous. Yeah. That's a big deal. The bowl. Is that a part of like you being like a little bitch? I am a little bitch. Of what you were saying earlier. Sorry, you brought it up, not me.
我会紧张的。对。那可是件大事。露天剧场。这算不算是你有点像个小碧池的表现？我确实有点像个小碧池。正如你刚才所说。抱歉，是你先提出来的，不是我。
Yeah. I would have faked it though. But he found the time to comb his hair today, which is nice. I didn't expect one of you to be in a tank top. I know, I'm sorry, it's not a tank. It's not a tank. It's a sleeveless t-shirt like Justin Thoreau. Is it from Thoreau's target line?
对。不过我会装出来的。但他今天倒是抽出时间梳了头，这挺好的。我没想到你们会有人穿背心。我知道，对不起，这不是背心。这不是背心。这是像贾斯汀·塞洛克斯那样的无袖T恤。这是塞洛克斯在塔吉特的服装系列吗？
He's got a new line at Target, doesn't he? He wishes, he should have a line at Target. Obviously, I thought you guys meant Thoreau. Oh, no. Is that from the Rowe? That would be a good way for him to market. The Rowe. Yeah.
他在塔吉特有新服装系列，对吧？他倒希望如此，他应该在塔吉特有个服装系列。很显然，我以为你们指的是梭罗。哦，不。那是来自The Row吗？那对他的营销来说是个好方法。The Row。对。
No, I was at the gym. Pardon my appearance. Jennifer, so nice to meet you. do we find you today? Jesus. I am in my bedroom in New York. I'm in my car. My first car.
不，我刚从健身房出来。请原谅我的仪态。珍妮弗，很高兴认识你。我们今天在哪里找到你呢？天哪。我在纽约的卧室里。我在车里。我的第一辆车。
If you had to live in a car, what kind of car do you think it would be? Oh, good course. Like a camper van. Yeah. How about, Willie, I haven't talked to you about this. The new VW electric bus
如果你必须住在车里，你觉得会是什么车？哦，好问题。就像露营车那样。对。威利，我还没跟你聊过这个呢。新款大众电动巴士，
that you drive in your new movie? It's rad. Yeah. I know. It's really cool. But that car was, like, I fantasize it. I want that car.
就是你在新电影里开的那辆？太酷了。对。我知道。真的很酷。但那辆车，就像是，我一直在幻想。我想要那辆车。
Is it great? Yeah. I mean, it's, yes. Listen to how careful he has to be with his GMC contract. And I'm thinking about my Hyundai thing right now and thinking, we've got to cut this. But I think that things pretty...
很棒吗？对。我是说，是的。听听他对通用汽车合同有多小心翼翼。我现在也在想着我的现代汽车代言，心想，我们得剪掉这段。但我认为那辆车挺……
I'm a Volvo gal myself. Are you? Wait, do you do the Volvo voice? X-C-90. What? No, you're not... You don't do the voice. Oh, no, I just drive a Volvo.
我自己是个沃尔沃迷。是吗？等等，你会模仿沃尔沃的声音吗？XC-90。什么？不，你不是……你不会模仿那个声音。哦，不，我只是开沃尔沃。
You drive. Oh, you do. An Audi, I'm an Audi. No one's asking. My husband's an Audi guy. Is he? Yeah. Well, this is what it's like to be one of the guys.
你开。哦，你真的开。奥迪，我是奥迪党。没人问你。我丈夫是个奥迪迷。是吗？对。好吧，这就是当个爷们儿的感觉。
This is one of the cars. Wait. Yeah, but I would say, to answer your question, My question would be a GMC-UConn-X-L-Denali funnel. Oh, Jesus. Wait, where are my questions? Here I come.
这也是其中一辆车。等等。对，但如果要回答你的问题，我的回答会是一辆GMC育空XL德纳利全尺寸SUV。哦，天哪。等等，我的问题呢？我来了。
Blue, I have a blue one. Sorry. All right. Is it Jen or is it Jennifer? Jen. Jennifer, if you're, like, trying to get my attention. Jennifer, if I'm scolding you. Jennifer.
蓝色，我有一辆蓝色的。抱歉。好吧。你是叫珍（Jen）还是珍妮弗（Jennifer）？珍。珍妮弗，如果你……就像是想引起我的注意。珍妮弗，如果我在训斥你。珍妮弗。
What about how cool that middle name Schrader is? I like that. Yeah, I didn't care about it growing up, but... You didn't like it? Yeah, no. That's cool. Is that a family name? Can you imagine if it wasn't a family name?
中间名叫施雷德不是很酷吗？我喜欢这个。对，我小时候不在乎这个，但是……你不喜欢？对，不。挺酷的。那是家族名吗？你能想象如果这不是家族名的话吗？
name. It's my grandma's maiden name. That's a great first name. Because Jason hasn't bothered to get to this, where are you from? I don't know enough about it. I don't know enough about you. I want to know. I want to know.
名字。这是我奶奶的娘家姓。真是个好名字。因为杰森还没费心说到这儿，你是哪里人？我对这不太了解。我对你了解得还不够多。我想知道。我想知道。
Guess. Guess? Guess. Guess? Yeah. Guess. I feel like this is kind of well known. I wonder if there's a state that will offend me.
猜猜。猜猜？猜猜。猜猜？对。我觉得这应该挺出名的。我在想会不会有一个州会冒犯到我。
Can I tell you, there might be. Can I tell you something? It's because the first time I think that I saw you in something was, is it is, maybe I'm going to tell you. Winterbone. I think of you of being from like Missouri. Appalachia. Or Appalachia or whatever it is.
我能告诉你吗？可能会有。我能告诉你一件事吗？因为我第一次看你演的作品是……是不是，也许我要说出来了。《冬天的骨头》。我觉得你像是来自密苏里州。阿巴拉契亚。还是阿巴拉契亚什么的。
That's in my mind. That's how great you are in that. Oh, thank you. So I'm going to say you are from... Take your time well. Can I just say West Virginia? You can. Again, adjacent.
这就是我脑子里的印象。你在里面的表现太棒了。哦，谢谢你。所以我要说你是来自……慢慢来。我可以直说西弗吉尼亚州吗？你可以。不过，差不多。
Kentucky, all right? Kentucky. Oh, okay. All right? How about that? Yeah. Yeah. Now, that's my first question.
肯塔基州，对吧？肯塔基。哦，好吧。对吧？怎么样？对。对。好，这是我的第一个问题。
You grew up in Kentucky with two older brothers, Jen. And you have said that you were always a tough kid. How do you think that environment shape the kind of roles you were grabbing? See, this is not. What I need to do, I got to read the questions first, and I'm going to make them my own. Are we still rolling? This is such a loose operation.
你在肯塔基州长大，有两个哥哥，珍。你说过你一直是个坚强的孩子。你觉得这种环境如何塑造了你后来接演的角色类型？看，这不是……我该怎么做，我得先把问题读一遍，然后把它们变成我自己的风格。我们还在录吗？这节目太随性了。
Hey, you're not wearing a shirt. So you got two brothers. You got it. All right. So, but now, do you think, here's the way I would phrase a question. All the roles that you play, they do, you shut up.
嘿，你没穿衬衫。所以你有两个哥哥。行吧。所以，但是现在，你觉得，我是这么措辞这个问题的。你扮演的所有角色，它们确实……你闭嘴。
They have a, they have a, they have a, they have a sass to them. And do you think that the sass is in the part, or do you bring the sass to it? Ah. Thank you. Oh, goodness. I mean, most of the time, yeah, it's in the part. I recently saw Merrill Streep say a quote that was, you know,
它们有一种……它们有一种……它们有一种……它们有一种厚脸皮的劲儿。你觉得这种泼辣劲儿是剧本里自带的，还是你把它带到角色中去的？啊。谢谢。哦，天哪。我是说，大部分时候，对，是剧本里有的。我最近看到梅丽尔·斯特里普说过一句名言，就是，你知道，
she seems like she knows what she. she's doing. She was like, it's about like finding the similarities between the two of us and like bridging a gap. And I was like, okay, so that'll be my thing too now. Right. But I feel like that. I try to do that mostly because I like you, I'm completely untrained and it's all just sort of like for me, I don't want to make this about me, but we're going to for a second, I kind of try to find what is the part of me that's closest to the part. And it seems like, because I never catch you acting, that it seems like you're staying
她看起来像是知道自己在做什么。她说，这就像是找到我们两人之间的相似之处并架起一座桥梁。我想，好吧，那我以后也这么办吧。对。但我觉得……我尽量这么做，主要是因为我和你一样，完全没有接受过专业训练，对我来说这一切都有点像……我不想把话题扯到我身上，但我们先聊一会儿……我试图找到最接近这个角色的那一部分自我。而且看起来，因为我从来没有捕捉到你在演戏的感觉，你似乎一直留
inside your goalposts, your, the limits of what different parts of Jen is. You have no limits in my view, sorry. Yeah. You know? Would that be fair that maybe you were doing what Merrill was talking about and she just kind of put words to it?
在你的球门范围内，也就是不同类型的珍的极限之内。在我看来你毫无极限，抱歉。对。你知道吗？这是否算公正地说，你其实在做梅丽尔所说的事，而她只是把话说出来了？
Yeah, I think that's fair. Where's everybody from? Can we do a roll call? Yeah. Sean? I'm from Chicago, Illinois. I love Chicago. Isn't Chicago? Isn't Chicago great? Yeah, the vibe is cool. This is a slippery slope, Jen. What he loves to talk about Chicago?
对，我觉得挺公正的。大家都来自哪里？我们点个名吧？好。肖恩？我来自伊利诺伊州芝加哥。我爱芝加哥。芝加哥不是很棒吗？对，这里的氛围很酷。这是个危险的话题，珍。他最喜欢聊芝加哥了？
Oh, my God. There we go. It's pretty fantastic. People from Chicago, they really love it. In the suburbs, like right outside of Chicago. No way. By the way. This is my high school.
哦，天哪。你看这不来了。简直棒极了。芝加哥人，他们是真爱。住在郊区，就像芝加哥市郊的那种。不会吧。顺便说一句。这是我的高中。
I'm wearing the T-shirt. Are you serious? What are the odds? And then she mentioned it and then you're wearing it. Yeah. Jen, why do you love Chicago so much? You have you done time there? Done time.
我正穿着这件T恤呢。真的假的？几率有多小？然后她提到了这个，紧接着你就穿了它。对。珍，你为什么这么喜欢芝加哥？你在那儿待过一段时间吗？待过一段时间。
It's about 16 months up in Chicago. I had like cousins that lived there, so then I would go and visit as a kid. Have you ever worked there? No, I've never worked there. Yeah, it's pretty cool. Your cousins in one of those suburbs, like in planes, trains and automobiles,
我在芝加哥待过大约16个月。我有些表亲住在那里，所以我小时候会去那儿串门。你在那儿工作过吗？没有，我从来没在那儿工作过。对，挺酷的。你的表亲住在那些郊区里吗，就像《落难见真情》里那样，
when he comes home to that house for Thanksgiving, that to me, that's the idyllic suburban. You know that's like the only Thanksgiving movie? I put it on yesterday for my 13-year-old as a Christmas movie, and she saw in the little synopsis right before I click play. She goes, wait a second, this is Thanksgiving. I'm like, it doesn't matter. It's a great holiday movie.
当他回家过感恩节时，对我来说，那就是田园诗般的郊区生活。你知道那是唯一一部感恩节电影吗？我昨天把它当作圣诞电影放给我13岁的女儿看，就在我点击播放之前，她看到了简短的剧情简介。她说，等一下，这是感恩节。我说，没关系。这是一部极好的节日电影。
She goes, no, I'm out. Sounds like you're a kid. Yeah, but Jen, you know, it was wild. I was a teenager growing up in Chicago when John Hughes wrote and filmed all of them surrounding me, like in all the neighborhoods around. And I was in high school when they would come out, pretty in pink, you know, home alone or whatever.
她说，不，我不看。听起来你才像个小孩。对，但珍，你知道的，太疯狂了。我在芝加哥长大当青少年的时候，约翰·休斯正在我周围所有的街区里写剧本和拍电影。当它们上映时我还在上高中的，比如《粉红佳人》、《小鬼当家》之类的。
Per's Bueller. but Ferris Bueller, like all those so was like, wow, and it was so enamored. We're talking about your affinity for Ducky and how much you identified with Ducky. I would call Ducky all the time. No way. Shocker. But anyway, but did you, so that was the thing that influenced me was being a, Hollywood coming to Chicago. And I was like, wow, it was so close to me.
还有《春天不是读书天》，像所有这些……所以我当时想，哇，太着迷了。我们在讨论你对达基的喜爱，以及你跟达基的共鸣有多深。我以前老是模仿达基。不会吧。震惊。不过不管怎样，但这，所以当时影响我的是好莱坞来到芝加哥。当时我就想，哇，它离我好近。
What was that for you in Louisville? Well, I just want to, it's interesting when your age lines up with the movies that are coming out. I had that with Harry Potter. I was like 11 when the books came out and like 12. What was Hollywood like in Kentucky? No, but men like what was the influence for you? What was the outside influence to go,
对你来说，在路易斯维尔的经历是怎样的？嗯，我只是想说，当你年龄的增长和上映的电影刚好合拍时，这很有趣。我拍《哈利·波特》时就有这种感觉。书出版时我大概11岁，12岁左右。肯塔基州的好莱坞是什么样的？不，我是说，对你来说影响是什么？当时的外部影响是什么让你觉得，
wow, I want to do that. Oh, well, I don't, I mean, really nothing. It never occurred to me that that would be a thing. Or possible, you know, I wanted to be a mom. I wanted to be an interior designer, which I'm not good at that. I just, that was a job option.
哇，我想做那个。哦，嗯，我不知道，我是说，真的没有什么。我从来没想过那会是一件事。或者觉得有可能，你知道的，我想成为一名妈妈。我想成为一名室内设计师，虽然我不擅长那个。我只是，那只是一个工作选项。
But anyway. And then I went to, New York with my mom on like a long weekend from school and we were watching street dancing in Union Square and I got like discovered. Oh really? Really? Were you a break dancer? Is that what you mean like breakdancing?
不管怎样。然后我和我妈妈在学校的一个长周末去了纽约，我们在联合广场看街头舞蹈，然后我就被星探发现了。哦，真的吗？真的吗？你以前是个霹雳舞者？你是说像跳霹雳舞那样吗？
I was waiting to get on the cardboard. Yeah. I did that too. That's crazy. No, I did not. No, she's kidding. Oh, I did it. That's cool.
我当时正等着上硬纸板上去跳呢。对。我也这么干过。太疯狂了。不，我没有。不，她在开玩笑。哦，我做过。太酷了。
Wait, street dancing. So what you were just watching and somebody saw you? Yeah, I didn't. We don't get a lot of that in Kentucky. So my mom and I were just like, what's this? And then somebody, what?
等等，街头舞蹈。所以你当时只是在看，然后有人看见了你？对，我没有。我们在肯塔基州可不常遇到这种事。所以我和我妈妈当时就像，这是在干嘛？然后有人，什么？
How were you discovered? Yeah, wait, well, what happened? This guy, like, came over and was like, I worked for a modeling agency, can I take your picture? And my mom and I were like, you know, had no survival instincts. We're like, sure, do you want to go to a hotel? Wait, wait. Do you want to take pictures of me?
你是怎么被发现的？对，等等，到底发生什么了？这个家伙走过来，说，我为一家模特经纪公司工作，能拍张你的照片吗？我妈和我当时就像……完全没有生存本能。我们俩就想：好啊，你要去酒店吗？等等，等等。你想给我拍照吗？
That seems like you want to take pictures. Furt, on, off, what do you think? Top's on? Wait, wait, wait, so they go, so this person comes up, I want to know this, so this person comes up and goes, hey we're from a modeling agency we want you to we want to sign you we want to do a picture whatever that that is that's sort of creepy and then what's the what's the progression from there how does that all how do you start making movies um i signed with an agency that allowed me to like act which was like
听起来你很想拍照。穿上衣服，脱掉衣服，你觉得呢？穿着上衣？等等，等等，所以他们走过来……我想知道这个，所以这个人走过来，说，嘿，我们是模特公司的，我们想签下你，我们想给你拍照片什么的……这听起来有点诡异，然后从那以后进展是怎样的？你怎么开始拍电影的？嗯，我签了一家经纪公司，允许我去演戏，也就是路易斯维尔的广告之类的，或者……这还是……不，我……所以我们不得不回回路易斯维尔，但既然我知道这是一个机会，我就觉得……而且，我……我其实赚过钱。我通过当保姆存了钱，我也驯过马。所以我有，你知道的，几千块钱。我就想：我要去。当时我14岁。
commercials and stuff out of louisville or this is still no i so we had to go back to louisville but now that i knew that this was an opportunity i was just like and um i i had to I had actually made money. I'd saved money from babysitting, but also I trained horses. And so I had, like, you know, a couple grand. And I was like, I'm going. And I was 14.
哇。起初是我哥哥陪我去的，他当时大约18岁。我们俩当时就想：我们死定了。等等，就你们俩？就我们俩。没有。去纽约。对。
Wow. And originally my brother came with me, who was like 18. And we were just like, we are going to die. Wait, just the two of you. Just the two of us. No. To New York. Yeah.
我们的第一顿饭是在时代广场的苹果蜂（Applebee's）吃的。不会吧。因为萨巴罗（Sabarro）关门了。对。我想我的第一顿是在M&M世界巧克力店之类的。但等等……最后一顿。她说的是第一顿。好吧。
Our first meal was at Applebee's in Times Square. No way. Because Sabarro was closed. Yeah. I think mine was at the M&M store or whatever. But wait, what about... Last meal. She said first meal. Okay.
你当时14岁，你哥哥当时多大？18岁。哇。你爸爸妈妈就说，太好了，去玩得开心点？对。我是说，他们很支持我。我知道作为父母听到这些会觉得有点奇怪。我是说，但当时的感觉就像是……
You were 14 and how old was your brother at the time? 18. Wow. And your mom and dad were just like, great, go have a good time. Yeah. I mean, they were supportive. I know that it's weird as parents to hear it back. I mean, but at the time it was like...
我觉得……我不知道。我觉得他们能看出这件事正在发生。所以他们尽量让它变得尽可能安全。对。对。所以他们安排我跟我哥哥一起去。所以你就辍学了？对，我辍学了。我本打算只去过个夏天，然后就回学校上学。但在夏天结束时，我接拍了一部在洛杉矶拍摄的情景喜剧。是《比尔·英格瓦尔秀》吗？
I think... I don't know. I think they could tell that this was just like kind of happening. And so they tried to like make it as safe as possible. Right. Right. So they gave, so they sent me with my brother. So you just dropped out of school? Yeah, I dropped out of school. I was supposed to, I was only going to do it for the summer and then come back for school. But at the end of summer, I had booked a sitcom that shot in L.A. This is the Billing Ball Show?
然后我本该像……你知道的，你本该毕业的，比如通过在家上学来修学分什么的……但我们就这么顺其自然了。顺其自然。对。哦，哇。就这么放任不管。是谁开车送你去的洛杉矶？是那个摄影师吗？
And then I was supposed to get like, you know, you're supposed to like graduate, like get homeschooled for your credits or whatever. but we just kind of left it. Left it. Yeah. Oh, wow. Leave it. And who drove you to L.A.? Was it the photographer?
开着一辆面包车。在一辆面包车里。我爸爸开着一辆黑色老车从肯塔基一路载我们到洛杉矶。哇。哇。我们为什么不坐飞机？我们在洛杉矶需要一辆车。
In a van. In a van. My dad drove us in the Black Era from Kentucky to L.A. Wow. Wow. Why didn't we fly? We needed a car in L.A.
我们在洛杉矶需要一辆车。好吧。而且我们做了一次完美的置换。我们把我们在纽约的公寓和别人在洛杉矶的房子互换了。这纯粹是个Craigslist（分类信息网）上的操作。哦，哇。你是说他们转租了你的公寓？
We needed a car in L.A. Okay. And we did a perfect swap. We swapped our apartment in New York for somebody else's house in L.A. And it was just a Craigslist situation. Oh, wow. They sub-let your apartment, you mean?
对，然后我们住他们的房子。这就像是一群吉普赛人。到处跑，追逐艺术梦想。我太喜欢了。我知道。就像《排练》第二季一样，这家伙要用摄像机拍你。然后他说：有多少人拒绝了？
Yeah, and then we take their house. It's just a bunch of gypsies. Just running around the country, chasing an artistic dream. I love it. I know. It's like rehearsal season two and it's like, this guy's going to fly you on a camera. And he's like, how many people said no?
然后他说：没这回事。然后他说：演员啊，老兄。对。那种极致的梦想家。我看过那个。挺好看的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。
And he's like, no button. And he's like, actors, dude. Yeah. Such intense dreamers. I saw that. That was good. and we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
所以你去了洛杉矶，你还是很幸运。所以这是联合广场事件几个月后。几个月后，你接拍了一部情景喜剧，挺早的。我们知道那是哪个情景喜剧吗，还是说只有一个试播集？《比尔·英格瓦尔秀》。剧名叫《比尔·英格瓦尔秀》。反响不是很好。我是说，它在TBS电视台播出，我有一段时间拿到了稳定的薪水。
So you're out to L.A., you're still fortunate. So this is months after this Union Square moment. Months later, you book a sitcom, like pretty early on. Do we know the sitcom, or was there just a pilot? Bill Engval. It was called the Bill Engval show. It didn't do very well. I mean, it came out on TBS, and I got a steady paycheck for a while.
而且在……我是说，大概两年、两年半的时间，然后我在那部剧的间歇期接拍了《冬天的骨头》，接着那部剧就被取消了，时机堪巧完美。哇。所以，这最初……就像雨水取消了我们的演出一样。这简直就像……这就像下雨一样。这是一种祝福。
And on the, I mean, for like two. years, two and a half years, and then I booked Winter's Bone on the hiatus of that show, and then the show got canceled, which was perfect timing. Wow. So were, this first... And just like the rain canceling our show. It was just like... It's just like the rain. It's a blessing.
这是上天的眷顾。但这种最初接触表演的经历，感觉像是一个早期的契合点。这是你觉得舒适的事情。这是你想做一辈子的事情。它让我觉得太舒适了，以至于我总觉得事情应该更难一些。所以我记得
It's looking down. But this first exposure to acting and stuff, it felt like an early fit. This was something that you, it was comfortable. This is something I want to do the rest of my life. It was so comfortable that I found ways I thought it had to be harder. So I remember
或者像我会读剧本试镜，我会读台词。我会想：好吧，正常人会这么说。然后我会改变它，心想：也许我会这么说。对，对，对，对。嗯，不过这真的很有趣，因为人们确实……我不知道，
or like I would like read like an audition, like I would read sides. And I'd be like, well, this is how a normal person would say it. And then so I would change that and be like, so maybe I will say it like this. Right, right, right, right. Well, that's really interesting though, because people do, they, I don't know,
我觉得有些人……奉献出色的表演就能获得提名。而另一些人只是表现得很自然，融入其中，让故事主导一切，却不会像那些炫技型的表演演员那样受到那么多关注。你的表演如此自然，然而你却获得了难以置信的……
I feel like some people like, that give like performances will get like nominations. And then other people that just kind of like just do naturalistic, just kind of disappear, let the story take over, don't really get as much attention as like the flash. sort of performance actor. You're so naturalistic, yet you are incredibly well,
该怎么称呼呢，获奖，获得提名？得到认可。得到认可，谢谢。我生病了，伙计们。所以，我喜欢这样。你觉得这可能是因为你没有去读表演学校
what would you call, awarded, nominated? Recognized. Recognized, thank you. I'm sick, you guys. So that is, I love that. Do you think that maybe that's because you didn't go to acting school
并学习如何演戏吗？你知道吗？你知道，我妈妈曾带我去见了一个经纪公司推荐的人。别担心，结局不是那样的。好吧。但我妈妈带我去了那个经纪公司推荐的家伙那里，为了帮我
and learn how to act? You know? You know, my mom took me to some guy that like the agency. Don't worry, it doesn't end like that. Okay. But my mom took me to this guy that this agency told me to me to help me
学习演戏什么的。对。他告诉我妈妈，别让她去上任何……你知道的，表演课。别这么做。那个偶然的家伙就是泰勒·谢里丹。哦，哇。真诡异。
act or whatever. Right. And he told my mom, don't put her in any, you know, acting lessons. Don't do that. That guy randomly is Taylor Sheridan. Oh, wow. Weird.
等等，什么？这不是太疯狂了吗？我猜他以前是个表演老师什么的。太疯狂了。等等。我觉得他曾经是，我觉得他的故事是他曾经是个演员，对吧？然后开始写作并写了……《边境杀手》。
Wait, wait, what? Isn't that crazy? I guess he was like an acting teacher or something back in the day. That's crazy. Wait. I feel like he was an, I think his story is that he was an act.
那阵子火了一阵子。还有，德尼……对，很棒。丹尼斯发现了它。还记得他讲过那个故事吗？他只是……他偶然发现了它。就像是：等等，这是我读过的最伟大的剧本。为了特蕾西，好让她知道泰勒·谢里丹创作了《黄石》。我觉得特蕾西不需要在这上面得到任何帮助。
actor, right? And then started writing and wrote... Sicario. That was kind of around for a while. And, DeNi... Yeah, it's great. And DeNee found it. Remember he told that story? He just... He kind of found it. It was like, wait, this is the greatest script I've ever read. For Tracy, just so she knows Taylor Sheridan created Yellowstone. I feel like Tracy doesn't need any help on that one.
对，对。好吧，她可能需要。她可能需要。所以他当时也是……所以他当时也在教表演。太惊人了。我太喜欢这个建议了。别带她去上表演学校。她自己会学会演戏的。
Yeah, yeah. Well, she may. She may. So he was also... So he was also teaching acting. That's amazing. I love that note. Don't take her to acting school. She'll learn how to act. and what a great piece of advice that was because you don't do that. You're very easy to watch, Mrs.
这是一个多么棒的建议啊，因为你确实没去过。你演起戏来看起来非常轻松，夫人。哇，所以泰勒·谢里丹就是那个人。所以你们俩有谈过合作吗？那段关系还有后续吗，还是没有？只有那段短暂的接触，然后你就继续前进了。不，只有那段短暂的接触。哇。从那以后你们就没遇见过吗？不，我们曾因为另一个项目碰过面，
Wow, so Taylor Sheridan was the guy. So did you, have you guys ever talked about doing somebody? Was there any follow-up to that relationship or no? It was just that brief period and then you moved on. No, just that brief period. Wow. And you haven't run into him since. No, we met up about like another project,
但我们没有聊起这个，因为我甚至不知道我们当时有没有把这件事联系起来。两三年前我在为一个电影做问答时，有人帮我把这件事联系了起来，所以我们俩当时可能根本不记得这层联系了。哦，对，我懂。我是说，他怎么会记得？我当时只是个小孩子，对吧？我们把他请上节目吧。
but we didn't talk about it because I don't know if we even made the connection. somebody made the connection for me when I was doing a Q&A for a movie like two or three years ago so we just might not even remember that connection oh yeah I know I mean why would he I was just like a little kid right let's get him on the horn
对，太疯狂了。好吧，所以所有的……所以演戏感觉很舒适，你得到了一些不错的……你得到了不错的工作，你拍了《冬天的骨头》，而且《冬天的骨头》让……肖恩愿意付出一切来换取一部《冬天的骨头》。
yeah that's wild all right so all the so the acting is comfortable you're getting some good you're getting good jobs you get Winter's bone and winter's bone gets Sean would give anything to have a winter's bone.
你愿意吗？对。我什么都不愿意付出。你什么都愿意付出。因为你的熊在冬天会进入冬眠，对吧，肖尼？对，没错。我们这不就说通了吗。直到春天。
What do you do? Yeah. Don't give anything. You give anything. Because your bear goes into hibernation during the winter, right, Shoney? Yeah, exactly. We got it right there. It's not until spring.
那个小熊直到春天才会拿着手机回来。他们为自己感到骄傲。她太……太有趣了。太有趣了。现在我们渐入佳境了。说得好，伙计们。所以等等。
That little cub doesn't come back with a phone until spring. They're so proud of themselves. She's so... It's so fun. It's so fun. Now we're cooking with gas. Good bit, guys. So wait.
所以，珍。现在《冬天的骨头》上映了。每个人都爱珍妮弗·劳伦斯。是的。看来我们的职业生涯有着落了。现在看来我们真的不需要去上学了。那其实已经决定了，但现在这件事巩固了它，对吧？对。
So, Jen. So now Winter's Bone comes out. Everybody loves Jennifer Lawrence. Yes. Looks like we've got a career ahead of us. And now it's we really don't need to do the school thing. That was already kind of decided, but now this solidified it, right? Yeah.
嗯，到那时，我是说，我到现在还是这种感觉。我还是会感到不知所措。就像当我听说某人大学毕业了什么的，我对那种条理性能到这种程度甚至仅仅是拥有学分或者知道……我甚至不知道该从哪里开始。我觉得我得从六年级左右重新开始。管他呢，我又不用去。我时不时会感到焦虑，担心自己非得去上学不可。
Well, by then, I mean, I still feel this way. I still feel overwhelmed. Like when I hear that somebody, like, graduated or something, I have envy of the, like, organization of even just, like, having the credits or, like, knowing how to, I wouldn't even know where to get started. I think I would have to start from like sixth grade or something. Whatever, I don't have to do it. I get anxiety randomly that I'll have to do it.
但你对错过学业没有任何遗憾吗？以前有过。现在没有了。但我当时真的很孤独。我小时候没有社交生活。作为一个青少年，我没有朋友，你知道的。对。对。
But you don't have any regrets about missing out on it. I did. Now I don't. But I was really lonely. I didn't have any social life as a kid. I didn't have any friends, you know, as a teenager. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，那你以前不得不在片场上学吗？你被解放了吗？没有，我想这就是我们那样做的原因，因为如果你没有被解放，那么如果你未成年，他们就必须为你支付家教的费用。
Well, but did you ever have to go to school on set? Were you emancipated? No, that's why we did. did it, I think, because you have to pay if you're not emancipated, then they have to pay for a tutor for you if you're underage.
所以为了让我更有吸引力，我们当时说我已经有了普通教育发展证书（GED）。所以我们不需要片场家教，我是一个廉价的未成年人。于是我妈让当时的男朋友用微软Word打印了一份GED或毕业证之类的东西。
And so our way of making me enticing, I think, was that we said I had a GED. So we didn't need the onset tutor, so I was an inexpensive minor. So my mom had my boyfriend at the time print out like a GED or a diploma or something
而且片方又不是那种会说：嘿，让我们查证一下的人。所以那是假的。假的。假GED。对，那是假的。天哪，我太喜欢这家人了。
on, like, Microsoft Word. And it's not like a studio was going to be like, Hey, let's check this out. So it was fake. Fake. Fake G. Yeah, it was fake. God, I love this family.
用的是像微软Word这种软件。而且也不会有哪个工作室跑来看：嘿，来看看这个。所以这是假的。假的。假黑帮。对，是假的。天哪，我太爱这个家族了。
This family is incredible. Yeah, you should see it at Christmas. We really rip. All right, but now, because I don't know. My mom one time I brought like a British boyfriend home, and they had in celebration of me coming home, roasted a pig on a spit. And my boyfriend was very fancy,
这家人太不可思议了。对啊，圣诞节的时候你来看看就知道了。我们真的很疯狂。好吧，不过现在，因为我不知道。我妈有一次我带了一个英国男朋友回家，为了庆祝我回家，他们烤了一整只乳猪。我那个男朋友非常讲究，
and I don't think like wanted to eat it, but was being polite and was eating it. And my mom was like, when I saw that naked, pig on the spit. I couldn't help myself. I leaned right in and gave it a kiss. And wouldn't you know it? Two weeks later, I got ringworm. No way. Must meet your mom. Making a know. Oh my gosh. But I, you know, I don't have a high school diploma either and I get very, very jealous of people that are in college, that are listening to like professors, give lectures. But it's so funny because then I hear both
而且我觉得他其实并不想吃，但为了礼貌还是吃了。我妈就说，当我看到那只光溜溜的烤乳猪时，我实在忍不住了。我直接凑过去亲了它一口。你猜怎么着？两 semanas 以后，我得了癣。绝不可能。我一定得见见你妈。记下来。哦天哪。不过我呢，你知道，我也没有高中毕业，而且我对那些上大学的人、听教授讲课的人感到非常非常嫉妒。但这就很有趣了，因为后来我听你们两个，
you, Jay and you, Jennifer, talk about that. Sorry, Jen. And, and it's like that we all, okay, S-H. Yeah. Yeah, that, I know, that's my initials are, that, what was going to say? That, from your perspective, you were like, oh my God, I'm so jealous of people who went to college. But as a kid who wanted to act when I was really young, I was like envious of you guys. I was like, oh, that seems. But are you envious now?
你，杰，还有你，詹妮弗，谈到这个。抱歉，珍。然后，感觉我们都，好吧，S-H。对。对，那个，我知道，那是我的名字首字母，那个，我刚才要说什么？那个，从你的角度来看，你会觉得，天哪，我太嫉妒那些上过大学的人了。但作为一个很小就想演戏的孩子，我当时其实很羡慕你们。我会想，哦，那好像。但你现在还羡慕吗？
Yeah, not really. Well, I like my experience quite a lot, yeah. You did. I mean, you're a hilltopper for life, obviously. That's right. That's what the T-shirt says of his school. J.B., I didn't realize that we had so much in common like this. I mean, but what was your way to self-educate?
对，其实不怎么羡慕了。嗯，我很喜欢我自己的经历，是的。你确实。我的意思是，你显然是个永远的“山顶人（Hilltopper）”。没错。那就是他学校T恤上写的。JB，我以前没意识到我们有这么多共同点。我是说，不过你的自学途径是什么？
Mine was watching Charlie Rosen and trying to read newspapers. Yeah, I watched a lot of like the History Channel and Animal Planet. I would go to the library, I didn't have like a library card. My family, we just weren't like organized. We didn't like pay for things. So I would go, but then I would just read about like. Did you sneak in?
我的是看查理·罗森（Charlie Rosen）的节目，然后试着读报纸。对，我看了很多历史频道（History Channel）和动物星球（Animal Planet）。我会去图书馆，我没有借书证。我的家人，我们就是那种不太有条理的人。我们不喜欢为办卡之类的事花钱。所以我会去，但我就只是去读一些关于。你是偷偷溜进去的？
Magic. The library. Read about magic? I'm going to get a degree in magic. Yeah. I mean, left to my own devices. I mean, have you continued on the legacy of chaos in your own family moving forward? Do you keep a sort of a healthy dose of chaos?
魔法。图书馆。读关于魔法的书？我要去拿个魔法学位。对。我的意思是，随我自生自灭吧。我是说，你在自己的家庭生活中延续了这种混乱的传统吗？你有没有保持某种适度的混乱？
That's such a good question. I married somebody who is the opposite of me. He is so organized. He's an anchor. He's an anchor. Everything's ordered. Everything is ordered. Like on the sink.
这是一个太棒的问题了。我嫁了一个和我完全相反的人。他太有条理了。他是定海神针。他是定海神针。一切都井井有条。一切都井井有条。比如水槽上。
Like I have to, you know, like, keep the closet doors closed. And I have, like, my little jobs that I work really hard to do. What's the thing you just can't fucking do, God damn it? And he gets after you all the time. Jen, what's the matter with you? Why can't you blank? Right. Oh, I know, I know, I know, the schedule.
比如我必须，你知道，比如，把衣柜门关好。我有我自己的小工作，我非常努力地去做好它们。到底有什么事是你他妈的绝对做不到的，见鬼？然后他总是抓着你不放。珍，你到底怎么了？你为什么就不能空一下？对。哦，我知道，我知道，我知道，日程表。
So what, our kids, I mean, I'm, I get it now. I get it, but like they're on a very strict schedule, you know? It's like breakfast 7.30, like, I don't know. He does most of that. Well, he just keeps. He's good at keeping the time. He's good at keeping it, but we've learned to keep our marriage alive. I have a 15-minute wiggle room.
所以我们的孩子，我是说，我，我现在明白了。我明白了，但他们是按一个非常严格的日程表生活的，你知道吗？比如早上7点半吃早餐，之类的，我不知道。大部分都是他在搞定。好吧，他只是在坚持。他很擅长掌控时间。他很擅长掌控时间，但为了维持婚姻，我们学会了妥协。我有15分钟的弹性时间。
Right. Because I just, you know. You can't be held. to the precise times, otherwise the marriage is going to suffer. Yeah, because I can't. I will, yeah, I'm ADD. And I think I should go to like occupational therapy for that. But I don't know.
对。因为我就是，你知道。你不能被精确的时间死死套牢，否则婚姻就会出问题。对，因为我不能。我会，对，我有注意力缺陷多动症（ADD）。我觉得我应该为此去做个职业治疗什么的。但我不知道。
Is anybody here ADD? I think I am or I'm obsessive, consult compulsive a little bit. Like, or at least about being on time. Like I'm usually on time, but I'm never early. Because I feel like if I get someplace early, I'm wasting that amount of time because nothing's going to happen until it's supposed to happen. Oh, I don't know. I have to be on time or I get anxious.
这里有人有ADD吗？我觉得我有，或者我有点强迫症。比如，或者至少对准时有强迫症。比如我通常很准时，但我从不提前。因为我觉得如果我提前到了某个地方，我就是在浪费时间，因为在规定时间到之前什么都不会发生。哦，我不知道。我必须准时，否则我会焦虑。
But what I do is I picture what is happening, like what the day is, where it's going to be, where everything's happening. None of that is like confirmed or real. But my imagination about it is so strong. Like yesterday, we were going to the circus. We were going to go to the circus at 11. I didn't buy tickets.
但我的做法是想象正在发生的事情，比如今天是什么样的，要在哪里，所有事情都在哪里发生。这些都不是确定的或真实的。但我的想象力太强了。就像昨天，我们要去马戏团。我们原本打算11点去马戏团。我没有买票。
And then the next thing I knew, I looked at my phone and I was like building a snowman with my son in the backyard and it was 1230. And the circus was at 11. Like stuff like that. Like it's pretty toxic. Because you didn't see on the schedule or because what? I do follow the schedule.
然后接下来的事就是，我看了看手机，发现自己正和儿子在后院堆雪人，当时已经12点半了。而马戏团是11点开始的。类似这样的事情。这挺有毒的。因为你没看日程表，还是因为什么？我确实会遵循日程表。
Like I am like capable of doing that. But when I mess up, those are the mess ups. Yeah, yeah, yeah. How about like the iPhone was such? I used to be just in a sea of post-its before the iPhone. Like I couldn't remember anything. I was always like missing appointments. But now the iPhone with the little alarm situation,
比如我是有能力做到这一点的。但当我搞砸的时候，这些就是那些搞砸的时刻。对，对，对。iPhone不是挺……在iPhone出现之前，我以前总是生活在一片便利贴的海洋里。比如我什么都记不住。我总是错过预约。但现在有了iPhone和那个小闹钟功能，
little calendar. It doesn't work for me. Watch this. I tried it last night. Uh-oh. Siri, tell me I'm beautiful in one hour. I don't see I'm beautiful in your contacts. It just never does it.
还有小日历。它对我不顶用。看这个。我昨晚试过了。哦哦。Siri，一小时后告诉我我很漂亮。我在你的联系人里没找到“我很漂亮”。它就是从来不管用。
See? Yeah, I get it. And then it'll just, like, call my trainer. Because it wants to help you get beautiful. Listen. Yeah, it's very instinctual. What about a nice assistant? Let's get you a nice assistant or two.
看到了吧？对，我懂。然后它就会，比如，给我的健身教练打电话。因为它想帮你变漂亮。听着。对，这是非常本能的。那找个好助理呢？给你找个好助理或者两个怎么样？
Oh, I have a nice assistant. of the best. I love my assistance. But it's really hard what I put them through. I know, it's not that bad. I mean, my God, I'm a mother. My kids get to school on time. Yeah, yeah.
哦，我有好助理。顶尖的。我爱我的助理们。但我让他们经受的那些事确实挺难的。我懂，其实也没那么糟。我的天哪，我可是个母亲。我的孩子们按时去上学了。对，对。
Now, okay, so everything's cruising along, and it's feeling kind of normal. Winter's bone happens. And that's just like... Winter's bone happens. No, it wasn't exactly like that. I got nominated, but, you know, it was like...
好啦，所以一切都在顺利进行，感觉一切都挺正常的。《冬天的骨头》（Winter's Bone）出现了。然后那感觉就像……《冬天的骨头》出现了。不，其实不完全是那样。我被提名了，但是，你知道，那感觉就像……
At 20. It was an indie, and I still kind of felt like I was going to just be like an indie actress because I had starred in a couple other things that were like small and I had gotten like little awards for them like two other jobs. But you still have kind of an indie
在20岁的时候。那是一部独立电影，我当时还觉得我大概只会一直拍独立电影，因为我之前主演过其他几部规模很小的作品，并且凭它们得过一些小奖，就是另外两份工作。但你身上依然有一种独立电影的气质。
indie vibe like in the best way. I mean that as a compliment. Yeah, yeah, you do. I think it as a compliment. Thank you. You do. And so I was like, yeah, this is going to be, this is, I'm right on track.
独立电影的气质，以最好的那种方式。我是当成夸奖说的。对，对，你是有的。我是当成夸奖来想的。谢谢。你确实有。所以我当时想，是的，这会是，这，我完全走在正轨上。
I'm going to be like the indie lady. And then I auditioned for the Hunger Games. And then when I booked the Hunger Games, It was the same kind of season as like award season for, no way. That was silver linings. So I got famous just from booking Hunger Games. Oh, because the people who were fans of the book were like, oh, she's going to be. Yeah.
我要成为独立电影女王了。然后我去试镜了《饥饿游戏》。接着当我接下《饥饿游戏》时，那正好和颁奖季是同一个时期，绝不可能。那是《乌云背后的幸福线》的时候。所以我仅仅是因为接了《饥饿游戏》就出名了。哦，因为原著书迷们都在想，哦，她要演……对。
Yeah, because I used to do the Santa Monica Stairs. And I remember being like, I don't think I can do the Santa Monica Stairs anymore. I'm too famous. So then were you reluctant? You were reluctant to take that part? because you thought it was going to be too... Yeah. I thought it was going...
对，因为我以前经常去圣莫尼卡台阶（Santa Monica Stairs）。我记得当时我在想，我觉得我不能再去圣莫尼卡台阶了。我太有名了。所以你当时很勉强？你很勉强才接下那个角色？因为你觉得它会太……对。我当时觉得它会……
Yeah, Twilight had come out and it was like, holy fucking shit. Like, there were like helicopter pictures of them, like just trying to live in a guest house. And it just didn't seem like a nice life. And I had a good situation. Like, I had enough money for what I... You know, and I could do what I want.
对，《暮光之城》已经上映了，那感觉就像他妈的太疯狂了。比如，有直升机拍到他们试图在客房里过普通生活。那看起来实在不像什么美好的生活。而且我当时的情况很好。我有足够的钱来应付我……你知道的，而且我想做什么就能做什么。
Like, there was just... I didn't know if it was going to be worth it. You know, exciting, but maybe not ultimately worth it. And I did... I was always focused on, like, my future being a mom. And so I was like, I picture myself being a soccer mom, a minivan. And like, you know, and what if I'm, what if I can't do that? Because there's like, you know, I'm like Kim Kardashian or something.
所以当时就是……我不知道这到底值不值得。你知道，虽然令人兴奋，但可能最终不值得。而且我一直专注于一件事，那就是我的未来要成为一个母亲。所以我当时想，我能想象自己成为一个足球妈妈，开着小型面包车。然后，你知道的，如果我，如果我做不到呢？因为我感觉自己会像金·卡戴珊或者什么人一样。
But I thought about it. And then I said yes, and I don't regret it. But wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, before you said yes, well, take us through the sort of the deliberation process. Did you, did you reach out? Was it like agents, parents, friends, or all the above that helped you come to that decision? or was it just you running up the Santa Monica stairs and figuring it out? It was just me, you know, running up the Santa Monica stairs because there's not really anybody that can help you.
但我考虑了一下。然后我答应了，而且我不后悔。但等等，等等，等等，在你答应之前，让我们回顾一下权衡的过程。你有，你有找人商量吗？是经纪人、父母、朋友，还是以上所有人帮做出的决定？还是说只有你自己在圣莫尼卡台阶上跑步时想通的？只有我自己，你知道的，在圣莫尼卡台阶上跑步，因为其实没有什么人能真正帮到你。
Like, you know, mostly everybody's like, are you insane? You have to say yes to that. You're going to regret that for the rest of your life. And then taking time to, like, think about, I knew that I'd be connected to that character forever, which isn't good or bad. It was just something to think about. And I ultimately, I'm so happy about that.
就像，你知道的，基本上所有人都会说：你疯了吗？你必须答应啊。你会后悔一辈子的。然后花时间去思考，我知道我将永远和那个角色绑定在一起，这无所谓好坏。这只是需要考虑的一点。最终我对此感到非常高兴。
I love that. I know, isn't the new one about to come out? Like all these years later? Yeah. Yeah. Isn't it funny too? Like you, as an actor, you like work towards, you know, becoming successful. And then you have exactly what you're talking about, the struggle of, well, I know this is going to be successful. You know, do I associate myself with that?
我太喜欢这样了。我知道，新的一部不是快要上映了吗？这么多年以后？对。对。这不是很搞笑吗？作为一个演员，你努力工作，为了变得成功。然后你就会遇到你刚才说的这种纠结：好吧，我知道这一定会成功，我该跟它扯上关系吗？
But that's the thing where we want. We want to be successful. Anybody wants to be successful in any job they do. I know. But our job is very closely connected with our lives. Right. I mean, I guess everybody says. Yeah. So you say yes to the thingy at the Hunger Games, and then you get the nomination.
但这就是我们想要的。我们想要成功。无论是做什么工作，任何人都想成功。我知道。但我们的工作和我们的生活联系得太紧密了。对。我的意思是，我想大家都这么说。所以你答应了《饥饿游戏》那个事，然后你得到了提名。
And then my saying yes happened. Like that was announced in the same season as award season for Silver Linings Playbook. Oh, wow. Which I was like winning all of those awards leading up to that you win, like before you win the Big Daddy. And so I became the most famous person in the world. And I was like so. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it was fast.
然后我答应这件事发生了。那是在《乌云背后的幸福线》颁奖季的同一时期宣布的。哦，哇。当时我包揽了所有那些奖项，在赢得那个大奖之前，你懂的，在你赢得奥斯卡之前。所以我成了世界上最有名的人。我当时就……对，对，对。对，一切发生得太快了。
And tell me, an honest ratio between excitement and fear and panic. Oh, God, I don't know, because they blend. Right. It must have been exciting for a second. It was very exciting. It was so exciting. But I was also, like, working really, like, the whole time. I didn't have, like, during that era, I didn't have, like, more than.
告诉我，兴奋、恐惧和恐慌之间真实的比例是怎样的？哦，天哪，我不知道，因为它们混杂在一起。对。有一秒钟你一定觉得很兴奋吧。那真的很兴奋。太让人兴奋了。但与此同时，我一整都在疯狂工作。在那段时期里，我甚至没有……
two weeks off in like five years. So when I was like going to the awards things, when I won, I was shooting, catching fire. And I was like, I mean, even, yeah, I was like flying in and out to go to a party and then landing at four in the morning and then going to set for the Hunger Games at 7 in the morning. So just I don't think I ever got,
在五年里有过超过两周的假期。所以当我去参加颁奖典礼时，当我获奖的时候，我正在拍《星火燎原》。我当时就是，甚至，对，我就是飞来飞去参加个派对，然后凌晨四点落地，早上七点又去《饥饿游戏》的片场。所以我觉得我从来没有……
like by the time I finished the Hunger Games, they like came back to like the condo that I lived in when I was like a teenager because I just didn't. live anywhere. Right. And it was probably a great distraction to, like the craziness was a distraction to not absorb everything. Yeah, and I like lived with my best friend. So that was nice. That definitely stopped me from getting full of myself. But when the music kind of stopped, when you came back to the condo after all that time, did you feel like, oh my, did it feel like a, such a big part of your
等到我拍完《饥饿游戏》的时候，他们，我回到了我还是个十几岁时住过的公寓里，因为我根本没有在任何地方真正安家。对。而且那可能是一个很好的转移注意力的事，那些疯狂的状态成了一种转移注意力的东西，让你不用去消化所有这一切。对，我和我最好的朋友住在一起。所以那挺好的。那绝对阻止了我变得自我膨胀。但当音乐停下来的时候，当你历经这一切回到公寓时，你有没有觉得，哦天哪，是不是觉得生命中的一大段……
life had just kind of gone by? You can't go to Starbucks anymore. And like all that stuff started to really kind of. Did it feel like a time warp? Yeah. Yeah, but you know what? It was like, I am a home body and I realized that I could use this to my advantage. And that was cool. I can just be like, oh, I can't come to your party. I'm too famous. I can't leave the house. Like being pregnant, right?
生活就这样悄然流逝了？你再也不能去星巴克了。诸如此类的事情开始真正地……这感觉像是一场时间穿梭吗？对。对，但你知道吗？当时我想：我是一个居家的人，我意识到我可以利用这一点为自己服务。这挺酷的。我可以直说：“哦，我不能去你的派对。我太有名了。我不能离开屋子。”就像怀孕一样，对吧？
You can just say, oh, yeah, no, I got to go. I got to leave early. Like being pregnant? Well, yeah, my wife. Do you do that like when your wife is pregnant? Yeah. It was like, it's a great way to get out of a party early or you have the baby at home, you know. Oh, yeah.
你可以直接说：“哦，对，不，我得走了。我得早点走。”就像怀孕一样？好吧，对，我太太。你会在你太太怀孕的时候这么做吗？对。这绝对是个早退派对的好借口，或者你在家带孩子，你知道的。哦，对。
Now with kids, you don't have to do anything. Sean still does it with his dog, Ricky. Yeah. Sean does it all the time. He's like, we've got to get back to Ricky. And we're like, at 7 p.m. You've been gone two hours. Did you leave a bunch of food out?
现在有了孩子，你什么都不用做了。肖恩还是会拿他的狗里奇（Ricky）当借口。对。肖恩经常这样。他会说：“我们得赶快回里奇身边。”而我们就会想：晚上7点钟诶。你才刚出来两个小时。你把一大堆吃的留下了吗？
No, well, I mean... Do you not have kids? I don't have... We don't have kids, no, but we have a dog. Not human kids. You have such calm dad energy. I know. You know what?
不，好吧，我是说……难道你们没有孩子吗？我没有……我们没有孩子，不，但我们有一只狗。不是人类小孩。你有一种非常淡定的父亲气质。我知道。你知道吗？
It's because I didn't have one. So, that's another podcast. But yeah, because I didn't have one. So I think... I have a fantasy of being a dad because of the way I wasn't fathered. but then we've had this conversation so many times about, you know, I've written like three jokes since you've been talking about just driving fast, about stick shift.
那是因为我没有孩子。所以，那是另一期播客要聊的。但对啊，因为我没有孩子。所以我认为……我对当爸爸有一种幻想，因为我自己的父亲并不是那样对待我的。但随后我们已经多次讨论过关于……你知道的，自从你开始聊开快车、聊手排挡以来，我已经顺便想了大概三个笑话了。
Go ahead, keep going. But yeah, no, but I always said neither me or Scotty, my husband is 100% wanting kids. And I was like, if he was 100% it was like, oh my God, I want him. I want him somebody. Then I'd be like, great, let's do it. But we're both like 85, you know, like so it's not fair to the kid. I do feel though that like during the nine months it takes to make a baby, it helps. That's a useful time for parents to kind of get their head around becoming parents.
行了，你继续。不过对啊，不，我总是说我和我老公斯科蒂（Scotty）都不是100%想要孩子。我当时想，如果他是100%想要的话，那就好像，天哪，我想要他。我想要某个人的孩子。那我会觉得：太棒了，我们生吧。但我们俩都差不多是85%的意愿，你知道的，所以这对孩子不公平。不过我的确觉得，生一个孩子所需的这九个月时间，其实挺有帮助的。对父母来说，这是一个适应并做好当父母心理准备的有用时期。
So take that for what it's worth. I don't know. Whenever anybody tells me like I'm not sure. I'm like, don't do it. Yeah. Because I feel it's so weird that people are like, oh, you don't have kids. You don't have kids. And then when you have a kid, you're like, what the fuck?
所以，这话见仁见智吧。我不知道。每当有人跟我说“我不太确定”时，我都会说：那就别生。对。因为我觉得人们那种心态好奇怪，他们会说：“哦，你没有孩子。你没有孩子。”然后等你有了孩子，你就会想：这他妈到底怎么回事？
Everybody should have been like, when I said, it should have been one out of a thousand people that goes, okay, I think I'm going to do it. And everybody's like, are you sure? Right, right, right, right. Like that's the way it should be. And it doesn't help, like I said this too, it doesn't help like while somebody's rocking their screaming baby,
每个人都应该……当我这么说的时候，一千个人里应该只有一个人会说：“好吧，我想我要生一个。”而现在每个人都问：“你确定吗？”对，对，对，对。这才是正常的相处方式。而且这根本无济于事，就像我以前说过的那样，当一个人正一边拍着他们大哭大闹的孩子，
you know, behind their back, they go, don't have kids. Yeah. You know, and like, okay, well, it's seen that enough. We're doing bits. It's just bits. We're doing bits. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
背过身去说：“千万别生孩子。” yeah。你知道的，好吧，这种场面我们见得够多了。我们在开玩笑呢。这只是个段落。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
But speaking of babies, Jen, now are you the soccer mom that you were dreaming about? Yeah. Are you tempted to like... I'm an ice hockey mom. No. Yeah. I never saw that coming in Kentucky.
但说到孩子，珍，你现在是你一直梦想中的那种足球妈妈吗？对。你有冲动想去……我是一个冰球妈妈。不。对。我从没想过在肯塔基会这样。
I'm an ice hockey mom. Yeah. Wait, the four-year-old is playing ice hockey? Yeah. Or is a dad? Yeah. No. The four-year-old.
我是一个冰球妈妈。对。等等，四岁的孩子在打冰球？对。还是他爸爸？对。不是。是四岁的孩子。
Yeah. Yeah. That's a cool. I mean, my husband played hockey growing up, and he's... That's so hot. when they play hockey together, like in the house. Like, it really turns me on. Is he Canadian?
对。对。那挺酷的。我是说，我老公从小就打冰球，而且他……那真的太性感了。当他们一起打冰球的时候，比如在家里。那真的让我很有感觉。他是加拿大人吗？
No, we'll almost, Vermont. Okay, good, yeah, yeah. We love hockey. Hockey's my sport. But what about that? Has that hockey gear started smelling yet on the four-year-old? Because the hockey gear is bad. No, he told me I had to brush my teeth yesterday.
不，差不多吧，佛蒙特州。好吧，很好，对，对。我们爱冰球。冰球是我的运动。但那个呢？四岁孩子的冰球装备开始发臭了吗？因为冰球装备味道可太大了。不，他昨天告诉我要刷牙。
Oh, do you're a husband or your kid? He was like, you should brush your teeth, Mommy. Yeah, they'll tell you straight. I used to have to bring my hockey equipment in the side and had to take it to the basement because it smelled. so bad. The hockey bag is the worst. My mom would be like
哦，是你老公还是你孩子？他说：“妈妈，你应该刷牙。”对，他们说话可真够直接的。我以前不得不把冰球装备带到室外，还得放到地下室去，因为味道实在太难闻了。冰球包简直是灾难。我妈妈会说……
I don't have that yet. Had to keep it in the boiler room at the house because it smelled so bad. Wait, so, but Jen, don't you just want to... What do you do about that? Baking soda? Nothing. It just is what it is, eh?
我还没遇到这情况。不得不把它放在屋里的锅炉房里，因为味道太重了。等等，所以，但是珍，你难道不想……你对此有什么办法？小苏打？没办法。事情就是这样，对吧？
You go buy new stuff. Yeah. Are you Canadian? I'm Canadian, yeah. Oh. Boy. Yeah, that'll stop. We'll tighten everything.
你就去买新的。对。你是加拿大人吗？我是加拿大人，对。哦。天哪。对，那话头得掐了。我们得收敛点。
It really landed. I'm tempted to just like not ever. work again and just be home with kids and like, yeah. That's, I identify as a stay-at-home mom. Yeah.
这话真戳中点上了。我有时候真想再也不工作了，就待在家陪孩子，然后，对。我认同自己是一个全职妈妈。对。
But I am obviously. When he says home and kids, he means on the golf course, but listen. I've lost my passion for that lately. I don't know what's going on. I know. Same here. You're just sick. You'll get it back. You'll say, yeah.
但他说的“家和孩子”显然指的是在高尔夫球场上，听着。我最近对这个失去热情了。我不知道怎么回事。我懂。我也是。你只是腻了。你会找回状态的。你会说，对。
No, but I do, I do love I love not doing anything. Like right now we're, listener, we're in the holidays, right now, this will air later, but the two weeks around Christmas and New Year's, I just love that there's nothing to do except just stay in your PJs, make a fire, and watch movies. Yeah, I love that. Yeah, nothing's required.
不，不过我确实，我确实喜欢什么都不做。就像现在我们，听众朋友们，我们正处于假期，现在，这期节目会晚些播出，但圣诞节和新年周围的两周，我就是喜欢什么都不用做，只需穿着睡衣，生个火，看电影。对，我喜欢这样。对，什么都不用做。
I'm not used to being busy like this. I normally, like, I have a busy, like, three months while I'm filming, you know. But even in that sense, it's calm because there is nothing else to do. Right. I just go to work. I do that. I come home, I sleep, and then I do it again. Right.
我不习惯这么忙碌。我通常会有这样一种状态：在拍戏期间忙上紧张的三个月，你知道的。但即使在那种情况下，内心也是平静的，因为没有别的事可做。对。我就去上班。做完工作。我回家，睡觉，然后周而复始。对。
And then like two weeks while you promote it is hectic. But like something like this, where I'm like doing the, I don't know. Right. So right now you're doing some campaigning and it's busy. You've got to do a bunch of stuff like this. How do you like doing stuff like this? I like doing stuff like this. This is like a fun conversation with interesting people.
然后宣传作品的两周时间会很忙乱。但像现在这样，我在做这个，我不知道。对，所以现在你正在做一些宣传活动，这很忙。你得做一堆像这样的事情。你喜欢做这种事吗？我喜欢做这种事。这就像是一场和有趣的人进行的有趣对话。
Right, as opposed to doing like a. When do they get here? But like Q&A's, you know, like a Q&A that like starts at 9, like 9 p.m. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, after the screen. How do you stay awake? What time do you go to bed?
对，而不是去做那种……他们什么时候到？但像是问答环节，你知道的，比如9点开始的问答，晚上9点。对。对。哦，在放映之后。你怎么保持清醒？你几点睡觉？
I have half an eye open at 8.30. Oh, I am in bed. Kindle is lit until like 9.15. And then I don't even have like Kendall light on normally by 915. So Kindle will put you to sleep? Yeah. The reading puts you to sleep. Yeah.
八点半的时候我连眼皮都快睁不开了。哦，我已经上床了。Kindle会亮到大概9点15分。然后到9点15分的时候，连Kindle的光我通常都不开了。所以Kindle能催眠你？对。阅读能让你入睡。对。
Yeah, Will's a big reader. You know, that's true. The older you get, I went to a couple parties that started at like 8 o'clock at night. I'm like, who starts a party at 8? Well, that one this weekend that I couldn't go to, started at 8. What time did you get there? I got there right at 8. Right at 8.
对，威尔是个狂热的读者。你知道的，年纪越大越这样，我去过几个晚上8点才开始的派对。我在想，谁会把派对定在8点开始？嗯，就是周末那个我去不了的派对，就是8点开始的。你几点到的？我正好8点到的。正好8点。
So you could leave at 8.30? I was planning on going to a Christmas party tomorrow, but it starts at 9. Yeah, what? That's rude. You know, all that means is that we're going to be drinking a lot. When you set your time start at 9, that means it's going to be a lot of booze. And I just, you can't be hungover with a 9-month-old. No.
这样你8点半就能走了？我本来打算明天去参加一个圣诞派对，但它是9点开始的。对，什么？这太粗鲁了。你知道，这只能说明我们要喝很多酒。当你们把开始时间定在9点时，那就意味着会有大量的烈酒。而你带着一个9个月大的孩子是绝对不能宿醉的。不。
No. It's just not an option. Wait, Jen, when you were imitating your mom, that was so funny, and she had, that southern, you know, drawl or twang or whatever. Did you have that and got rid of it or did you never have it? No, I had it and got rid of it. I listened to like CDs. Come on, really?
不。那根本不是个选项。等等，珍，刚才你模仿你妈妈的时候太搞笑了，她有那种南方口音，你知道的，那种拖长音或者怪腔怪调什么的。你以前也有这种口音然后改掉了，还是说你从来没有？不，我以前有，后来改掉了。我听那种CD。真的假的？
Did you really? Yeah. I did, but I mean, my agency gave me CDs and I listened to them and I did them and like repeated all of the things. But I think that probably just time. Time, yeah, time in Los Angeles. Especially that young 14, 50, you just start sounding like your surrounding. Yeah, I got rid of my Canadian accent, the same way.
你真的这么做过？对。我做过，我是说，我的经纪公司给了我一些CD，我听着它们，跟着练习，一遍又一遍地重复所有的发音。但我觉得大概也就是时间问题吧。时间，对，在洛杉矶待的时间。特别是那么小的时候，14、15岁，你自然而然就会开始听起来像你周围的人。对，我用同样的方法改掉了我的加拿大口音。
When? Get out, Sean. How dear you? You just said A and I think a boat. A boat. What part of Canada? I've worked there, so I know all the provinces. Toronto.
什么时候？得了把，肖恩。你怎么敢？你刚刚说“A”和“a-boat”（发音像船）。A-boat。加拿大哪个部分？我在那里工作过，所以我知道所有的省份。多伦多。
Oh, okay. Yeah. Cool. Big city guy. Yeah, I'm a big city dude. That's kind of my cross-to-me. I'm more familiar with the Quebec region. Okay.
哦，好吧。对。酷。大城市男孩。对，我是个大城市老兄。这算是我的一块心病。我更熟悉魁北克地区。好的。
Is that Montreal? That's the Montreal is in Quebec, yeah. Montreal's in Quebec, yeah. Beautiful part of the world. Here's a question I know Sean's going to love. You joke that you once fan girl too hard on meeting Jack Nicholson. What is your most recent embarrassing celebrity encounter? I think I, like, frightened Draco Malfoy.
那是蒙特利尔吗？蒙特利尔在魁北克，对。蒙特利尔在魁北克，对。世界上一处美丽的地方。这里有个问题，我知道肖恩一定会喜欢。你开玩笑说你以前见到杰克·尼科尔森（Jack Nicholson）时狂热过头了。你最近一次尴尬的名人偶遇是什么？我觉得我，好像把德拉科·马尔福（Draco Malfoy）给吓到了。
What's his name? Tom Feldman. Yeah, really? We were doing Fallon and, you know how dark it is? And those, like when you're, like, behind the curtain or whatever, it's so dark on the late shows. And I had finished and was walking out. He was going to go on after me.
他叫什么来着？汤姆·费尔顿（Tom Felton）。对，真的吗？我们当时在上法伦（Fallon）的节目，你知道后台有多黑吗？还有那些，比如当你站在幕后或者其他地方时，深夜秀的后台非常暗。我刚结束录制走出来。他要在我后面上场。
And I just was like, I was like scared him. Really? Yeah. You're so fan. You fan out. I know it's wild when you run into people that you kind of, that stuck with you because of a film when you were growing up or whatever
然后我当时就……我好像吓到他了。真的吗？对。你太狂热了。你追星太疯狂了。我知道，当你遇到那些因为你小时候看过某部电影而一直留在你记忆里的人时，那种感觉真的很奇妙，当你终于见到他们的时候。对。我知道。然后结果就是，你告诉他们你有多喜欢他们，然后他们人很好，接着对话就戛然而止了。对。对。对话就……我大概一年前刚偶遇了莫利·林沃德（Molly Ringwald）。我当时想，哦天哪。
and you finally see them. Yeah. I know. And then it's just like you say like you love them so much and then they're nice and then it just stops. Yeah. Yeah. The conversation just I just ran into Molly Ringwald like a year ago. I was like, oh my God.
我是说内森·菲尔德（Nathan Fielder）。他在一个派对上，我试着保持冷静。我想我保持住了。但对。我和他也有过同样的经历。我说他简直是太棒了，我是他的超级大粉丝。然后他说：“哦，天哪，谢谢你。”对话结束。
I mean Nathan Felder. He was at a party and I tried to keep. I think I kept my cool. But yeah. I had the same thing with him. I said that he was like the best and I'm such a big fan. And he was like, oh my gosh, thank you. End of conversation.
对。而且内森·菲尔德和拉里·大卫（Larry David）这些人，他们太有压迫感了，因为你喜欢的是他们的脑子，你非常欣赏他们的个性和头脑。你知道的，不仅仅是他们的作品。如果他们不喜欢我，那我为什么要喜欢我自己？我知道。你想融入进去。我们这是按件计酬的。
Yeah. And Nathan Fielder and Larry David are, they're intense because it's like it's their brain that you are so like, you like their personality and like their brain. You know, not just like what they do. Like if they don't like me. then why would I like me? I know. You want to get in there. We're billing by the aisle.
哦，天哪，这太启发人心了。我想得到他们的认可。好吧，这里还有一个麻辣火辣的问题。在《热辣快访》（Hot Ones）里，你坦白了自己在片场会吃一些奇怪的零食。你经历过的史上最奇怪的片场食物组合是什么，而你现在仍对此秘而不宣？我根本不知道那是什么意思。片场奇怪的食物。我只是吃片场休息区（crafty）有什么就吃什么。
Oh, my God, this is so revelatory. I want their approval. All right, here's another spicy hot question. Hot ones, you confess to eating weird snacks on set. What is your all-time strangest onset food combo that you now secretly stand by? I have no idea what that means. It's a weird onset. I just eat what's at crafty.
对，没错。我哥哥们以前觉得，我的早餐恶心透了。比如我会把坎贝尔鸡面汤（Campbell's chicken noodle soup）和金枪鱼沙拉混在一起吃。我懂。好吧。哇。肖恩，踩刹车。
Right, exactly. My brothers used to think that, like, my breakfasts were gross. Like I would have like Campbell's chicken noodle soup and like tuna salad. I get it. Okay. Wow. Sean, hump the brakes.
你表现得怎么样？听起来很好吃。肖恩刚刚……我最近自己也上了《热辣快访》。你表现得怎么样，威利？你把所有的辣酱都吃完了吗？说实话，我当时……
How did you do? That sounds delicious. Sean just like, I did hot ones just recently myself. How'd you do, Willie? Did you get all the way through it? If I'm being honest, I was like,
我很勉强才去参加的，因为我不喜欢吃东西。我不喜欢辣酱。所以我当时想，好吧，来吧。然后他们就开始了。贝特曼（Bateman）刚刚上过节目，他全部吃完了。对。但我当时塞满了胃药和抗酸片（Tums），
I was reluctant to do it because I don't like eating. I don't like hot sauce. And so I'm like, okay, here we go. And then they go. Bateman was just on and he made it all the way through. Yeah. But I was loaded up with like Pepto and Tom's,
哦，我吐了。真的吗？你吐了？对。等等，传说中牛奶真的管用吗？是的，牛奶管用。真的吗？确实管用。但倒数第三个辣酱，我忘了它叫什么了，好像叫“炸弹”还是什么的。
Oh, I threw up. You did? You did? Yeah. Wait, is it true that milk really helps that? Yes, milk helps. Really? It did help. But the third to last one, I forget it was like, I forget it was called like the bomb or something like that.
简直荒谬至极。我一直在把冰淇淋抹在嘴唇上，因为我以为我的嘴唇要掉了。听起来很恶心。听起来像个噩梦。不，那种感觉是当它袭来时真的令人恐惧。太 overwhelming（招架不住）了。太难受了。当时我想：我究竟要怎么应付这个局面？
It was so ridiculous. And I was rubbing the ice cream on my lips because I thought that my lips were going to come off. That sounds gross. It sounds like a dream. No, it's like truly frightening when it hits. It's overwhelming. It was rough. Like, how am I going to handle this situation?
你是吐在片场了还是回家才吐的？没有。当时唯一能缓解灼烧感的方法就是狂灌冰水。所以我猜发生的情况是，我喝了太多冰水，结果就吐了。哇。这就是为了卖我们的产品而经受的折磨。对。但其实，过程挺有趣的。
When did you throw up on the set there or when you got home? No. So the only thing that soothed the burning was chugging ice water. So I think what happened was I drank so much ice water that I threw up. Wow. This is the kind of torture we put ourselves through to sell our product. Yeah. But actually, it was pretty fun.
他是个很好的人，肖恩人超级好。对，他是个非常棒的采访者。非常棒。问题提得极好。顺便说一句，那些问题真的很好，而且都出其不意。有些问题出其不意到让我笑出了声。而你当时正挣扎于嘴里着火。而且我好喜欢他那种冷面机器人的风格。
He's a great, he's a super nice guy, Sean. Yeah, he's a very good interviewer. Very good. Very good questions. By the way, the questions are really good, and they're really from out of left field. It made me laugh a couple times how out of left field. And you're struggling with your mouth is on fire. And I love how, like, dry and robotic he is, too.
对。感觉就像是在谈一桩他妈的严肃生意。对啊。他就像个机器人。他只是反应没那么大，因为他习惯了。对，他习惯了。他是钛合金做的。太疯狂了。我发现他其实某种程度上在模仿你。
Yeah. It's like, it's fucking serious business. Yes. He's a robot. He just doesn't react as much because he's used to it. Yeah, he's used to it. He's made of titanium. It's insane. He actually kind of mirrors you, what I found.
比如，他吃东西的方式和你一样。他每一口吃的大小都跟你一样。这其中，我猜能给人带来某种安慰。就好像他陪你一起受罪一样。对。你只是拿了……那个可怜的家伙。他说每当他去餐馆时，人们都会给他送鸡翅。
Like, he eats the same way that you do. He takes the same size bites that you do. And there's some, I guess there's comfort in that. It's almost like he's in it with you. Yeah. Did you take just... That poor guy. He said whenever he goes to restaurants, people send him chicken wings.
哦，天哪。而肖恩显然梦想着这个。对。把它们送这儿来吧。对。好吧。这个呢？
Oh, boy. And he obviously Sean, dream. Yeah. Send him over here. Yeah. All right. What about this?
如果名气明天突然消失了，珍，你首先会去做的第一件事是什么？那些因为出名而现在无法做的事。哦。我不觉得。那其实不适用。我一直都在做各种事。那像去迪士尼乐园呢？
If fame disappeared tomorrow, Jen, what is the first thing that you would go out and do? That you can't do now because of getting recognized. Oh. I don't. That doesn't really apply. I just do stuff. What about like, well, like, will you do like Disneyland?
对，但我会去迪士尼。我会去的。你只是冲进去。然后，接下来会发生什么？我就是冲进去。如果发生什么？一大群人开始围着你，每个人都想用iPhone拍照。
Yeah, but I'll do Disney. I'll do it. You just rush it. And then, so then what happens? I just rush it. What happens if? like a big crowd starts to gather around you and everybody wants a picture on their iPhones.
你会满足他们吗？不，那从来没发生过。如果真那样我就会直接离开。我觉得带一大群保安还戴着帽子什么的，反而会吸引注意力。但绝大多数情况下，我只是遇到人们斜眼看着我，
Do you indulge? No, it never happens. And like I would just leave. I think that bringing like a big security guard and like wearing a hat and all that stuff, that attracts attention. But if for the most part, I just get people like looking at me sideways
心里在想：她长得好像那个人。对，你不想去招惹这种注意。所以我就会那样做。你不想去招惹它。我记得听过这个——有人曾经告诉我这毫无关联。我不敢相信我竟然在作这种类比。
being like she looks like that person. Yeah, you don't want to invite it. So I would just do that. You don't want to invite it. I remember hearing this is a guy's told me once this is not related. I can't believe I'm a man. making this connection.
但在城里骑自行车时不要戴头盔，因为，再次说明，这是一个糟糕的类比，但我已经陷得太深了。当你戴上头盔时，你是在向其他司机表明你是这套系统的一部分，你只是另一辆交通工具。
But riding your bike in the city that don't wear a helmet because, again, this is a terrible analogy, but I can't bail them too deep. That when you wear a helmet, you say to the other drivers that you're part of the system that you're just another vehicle.
但如果你不戴头盔，他们就会把你当成一个人来看待。所以当我在城里骑自行车时，我从不戴头盔。这听起来又是梭罗（Thoreau）的言论。你知道是谁说的吗？洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels），他这辈子都没在城里骑过自行车。对，天哪。
But if you don't have a helmet, that you recognize as a human. So when I ride my bike in the city, I never wear a helmet. This sounds like Thoreau again. You know who said it? Lauren Michaels, who's never been in a bike in the city in his life. Yeah, my God.
但他曾经那样跟我说过。他是像在讲一个好笑的笑话那样说的，还是说得很认真？不，他是认真的。不，他说：“你怎么不戴头盔？你这是在告诉其他车辆你加入了这场游戏。”因为我当时在考虑要不要开始戴头盔。他说：“别戴。”劳伦（Lorne）建议我别戴。
But he once said that to me. Did he deliver it like it was a good joke, or did he deliver it serious? No, he meant to do it. No, he said, wouldn't you put a helmet on? You're telling the other vehicles that you're in the game. Because I was considering starting to wear a helmet. He said, don't do it. He advised me, Lauren.
所以，如果你不戴头盔，他们对你就会更小心一些，对吧？没错。没错，因为他们看到你是一个有血有肉的人。好吧。我不知道为什么，但我觉得当加拿大人搞笑时，感觉挺奇怪的。因为搞笑的加拿大人实在太多了。嗯，有金·凯瑞（Jim Carrey）。
So, like, if you don't have a helmet on, then they'll be more careful around you, right? That's right. That's right, because they see that you're a human being. All right. I don't know why, but I find it. weird when Canadians are funny. Because there's so many of them that are funny. Well, there's Jim Carrey.
有吉姆，有马丁·肖特（Martin Short）。马丁·肖特有点……当然了。一旦你发现某人是加拿大人，你就会想：哦，理所当然。我也不知道为什么。约翰·坎迪（John Candy）？马蒂·肖特可能是其中代表。
There's Jim, there's Martin Short. Martin Short is kind of... Of course. Once you find out somebody's Canadian, you're like, of course. And I don't know what it is. John Candy? Marty Short might be one of the levels.
约翰·坎迪是加拿大人？当然。约翰·坎迪看起来绝对像是芝加哥人。好吧，我们知道为什么。我们刚才还在聊奇怪的扮演，我在列出名单。加拿大拥有深厚的搞笑人才板凳深度。如果我可以对你这么说的话。深厚，
John Candy's Canadian? Of course. John Candy definitely seems like he's from Chicago. Well, we know why. We were just talking about playing strange and I'm in the album bills. Canada has a deep bench. if I can to you. Deep,
全都是搞笑天才。这是一个冰球术语，像板凳球员，就像，你知道的。我猜我只是觉得，对我来说，
of funny people. That's a hockey analogy, like a bench, like a, you know. I guess I just, like, there's, to me,
加拿大没有什么创伤。就像，你们有免费医疗。你们的税收支付公立学校费用。每个人都那么好。所以你们到底……
there's no trauma in Canada. It's like, you have free health care. You, the, your taxes pay for public school. Everybody's so nice. Like, what are you,
我觉得幽默是痛苦中孕育出来的。也许是因为你们那里冷。我们只能硬挺过去。在，等等，在我们放她走之前，我们得——见鬼，
I feel like humor is formed from suffering. Maybe you're cold. We just suck it up. Before, wait, before we let her go, we've got, God damn it,
我们已经进入最后一分钟了。我们甚至还没聊正事。我们聊聊吧。我想聊聊琳恩·拉姆塞（Lynne Ramsay），我最喜欢的导演之一。你能，好吧，聊聊《死我所爱》（Die, My Love）吗？
we're in the last minute. We haven't even talked about the thing. Let's talk. I want to talk, Lynn Ransy's, one of my favorite directors ever. Can you please, okay, so die my love, right?
对吗？对？对，就是那部电影。太不可思议了。我看过了，非常喜欢。你能跟我们讲讲那段我猜一定很神奇的与琳恩·拉姆塞合作的经历吗？对，我的意思是，真的非常神奇。在我们进组之前就开始了，她开始谈论这个世界，
Yes? Yeah, that's the film. It's incredible. Saw it, love it. Can you tell us anything about what I'm assuming was a magical experience with Lynn Ramsey? Yeah, I mean, it really was. It started like before we got on set, she just kind of started like talking about this world
然后写这些场景。而且它不一定是按时间顺序来的，这很时髦也很酷。然后我们去了加拿大，那是卡尔加里，位于……如果那是的话，那里太美了。那是哪个省？不，阿尔伯塔省是。阿尔伯塔。
and then writing these scenes. And like it wasn't necessarily like in chronological order, which was funky and cool. And then we got to Canada to, it was Calgary, which was in... Where if that was, it was beautiful. What's the Ottawa province? No, Alberta is. Alberta.
而且……我随时奉陪你所有关于加拿大的问题。对，谢谢。不客气。在片中表现得不可思议，罗伯特·帕丁森（Robert Pattinson）也是。我等不及要看了。这部电影太棒了。我等不及要看了。
And... I'm here for all your Canadian questions. Yeah, thank you. You're welcome. incredible in that and so was Robert Pattinson. I can't wait to see it. The movie's so great. I can't wait to see it.
而且画面也太美了。我猜我们应该在肖恩之前看过了。我已经看过了。真的吗？你有没有一部心目中的影史最佳电影或者前两名？哦，肖恩。好吧，现在，我是说，《一战再战》（One battle after another）是我看过的最喜欢的电影。太不可思议了。
It's just beautiful too. I guess we'd just see it before, Sean. I already saw it. Really? Do you have a top movie of all time for you or top two? Oh, Sean. Well, now, I mean, one battle after another was my favorite movie I've ever seen. It's incredible.
还有，等等，你是个真人秀粉丝。你看过你老公的那些真人秀吗？他不怎么看那些？他前一阵子看过《范德庞普法则》（Vanderpump Rules），但现在我把他拉进来了。不过对，我现在看《南加州风云》（Southern Charm）、《盐湖城真正的家庭主妇》（Real Housewives of Salt Lake）和《贝弗利山真正的家庭主妇》（Real Housewives of Beverly Hills）。《无下限甲板》（Below Deck）呢？我们看《无下限甲板》吗？你知道的，我没法看《无下限甲板》，因为我搞不懂它们不同的衍生系列。
What about, wait, you're a reality TV fan. Do you watch any of those of your husband? He doesn't get near him? He got near Vanderpump for a while, but now I lost him. But yeah, I watch Southern Trump. Charm Real Housewives of Salt Lake and Real Housewives of Beverly Hills now. What about Below Deck? Do we go Below Deck at all? You know, I can't watch Below Deck because I cannot understand the different franchises of
太让人混淆了。我永远不知道哪一个是最新播出的。是《无下限甲板》？《无下限甲板：地中海》（Below Deck Med），还是《无下限甲板：澳大利亚》（Below Deck Australia）？我不知道现在播的是哪一个。你得把这些搞清楚。你必须弄清楚，当你在“无下限甲板”宇宙里时，不能有这种困惑。没错。你看过《叛徒》（Traitors）吗？比如，如果我搞混了会怎么样？会发生什么？我指的是哪个地区，我对省份显然充满热情。等等，肖恩，那是什么？你在描述混乱。
them. It's too confusing. I don't ever know which one is current. Is it Below Deck? Below Deck, Med, Below Deck, Australia. I don't know which one's happening now. You've got to be clear on those. You have to, there can't be confusion when you're in the below deck universe. Exactly. Do you ever watch traders? Like, what happens if I confuse? What would happen? What region I meant, I'm clearly passionate about promises. Wait, Sean, what was that? You're describing chaos.
你看过《叛徒》吗？《叛徒》。哦，等等，那是最近在英国播出的那个吗？对。对，太好看了。他们基本上是在玩“天黑请闭眼”（Mafia），DB，他们在玩杀人游戏。他们现在在美国也在拍这个，对吧？还记得去年新年我们每晚玩了多少次“天黑请闭眼”吗？
You ever watched traitors? Traders. Oh, wait, that's the one that was just in England. Yeah. Yeah, it's so good. Where they play mafia, basically, DB, they play mafia. And they're doing that in the States now, too, right? Remember last year at New Year's how much we played mafia every night?
你玩得太棒了。我不得不每晚主持，因为其他人。而且我都不能自己玩。我不得不每晚主持。要是没有那个，节目根本办不下去。你就是个指路明灯。你们玩过“碗”（bowls）吗？碗？
You were great at it. I had to run it every night because everybody else. And I couldn't even play. I had to run it every night. It wouldn't have lasted with that. You were a beacon. Do you guys ever do bowls? Boles?
你当时表现得很棒。我每天晚上都得去运行它，因为其他人……而且我都不会玩。我每天晚上都得去运行它。如果没有你，它根本维持不下去。你就是一盏明灯。你们平时搞过保龄球活动吗？保龄球？
What is it? Salad bowls. What's that? Everybody writes down something that's familiar to everybody. Like everybody would get it, you know, like Spider-Man, Donald Trump, like, cheese. Yeah. And then you put them, and then there's like stage one, which is you can say every, you can say a full sentence just without that word. Yeah.
这是什么？沙拉碗游戏。那是什么？每个人写下大家都熟悉的东西。就像每个人都能懂的那种，你知道的，比如蜘蛛侠、唐纳德·特朗普，还有奶酪。对。然后把它们放进去，接着有第一阶段，就是你可以说任何话，你可以说一整句话，只是不能带那个词。对。
And then the second, you can just say one word. And then the third is charades. Some people call it celebrity or what do they call it? Oh, it has a different name for everybody. Oh, that sounds very good. So the first round you do, yeah, you get one sentence to describe it, then you put them all back in the bowl in the second round. And it's always the same.
然后第二阶段，你只能说一个词。第三阶段是猜词游戏。有些人叫它名人猜词或者叫什么来着？哦，每个人对它有不同的名字。哦，听起来真不错。所以第一轮你做，对，你有一句话来描述它，然后在第二轮里你把它们全放回碗里。规则一直都是一样的。
So then you started getting these inside jokes with, you know, it's just like the same. It's very funny. Shawnee, you used to have great game nights. What happened? What's going on? Too much, too much. I love game nights. I see, a lot of people do.
然后你会开始有一些只有内部人才懂的梗，你知道的，就跟以前一样。非常搞笑。肖尼，你以前经常办很棒的游戏之夜。怎么回事？发生什么了？太多了，太多了。我喜欢游戏之夜。我懂，很多人都喜欢。
Too much to host. Let's get the game to organize. Let's get on down to Jamie and Nico's house and just fire up a big fat game night. Oh, yeah. I'll fly in. You know, it's game nights always happen where people are like into it and then you start it and then people kind of fall out because they get bored and then it's kind of...
主办太累了。要把游戏组织起来。去杰米和尼科家，然后大办一场棒极了的游戏之夜。哦，对。我会飞过去。你知道的，游戏之夜总是这样，大家一开始都很投入，然后你开始了，接着人们就有点淡出了，因为他们觉得无聊了，然后就有点……
Yeah, that's the bummer. I'm going to start doing Monjeon with my girls on Thursday. I love Mahjong. I don't know how to play yet. We're going to learn. It's just a matching game. Is that the one with the tiles? Yeah, you just match the tiles.
对，这就挺扫兴的。我打算从周四开始和我的闺蜜们玩麻将。我喜欢麻将。我还不会玩呢。我们要学。这其实就是个配对游戏。就是那种带牌的吗？对，你只要把牌配对就行。
That's it. Oh. Huh. That's it. Those are the rules. Really? Yeah. Yeah. That's all too much. Yeah.
就这样。哦。哈。就这样。这就是规则。真的吗？对。对。这就全都是了。对。
All right. Jennifer. Jen. J.B. Thank you. Sean. Will. Next time you're out here.
好吧。珍妮弗。珍。J.B.谢谢。肖恩。威尔。下次你们来这边。
Will shirt. Doing your things. Thank you. Let us know. And we'll play some Mahjong and some bowls. We'll do a game night at Shons. Yeah. We'll do some bowls.
威尔的衬衫。做你们的事。谢谢。让我们知道。我们会去玩点麻将和沙拉碗游戏。我们在肖恩家办个游戏之夜。对。我们玩点沙拉碗。
Sean's going to. Sean's going to do some pictures. Sean, I'll help you organize and I'll come early and we can set up appetizers and stuff. Yeah, right. Crutiton. Bullshit? Then I can like be. They're already out.
肖恩打算去。肖恩打算拍点照片。肖恩，我来帮你组织，我早点来，我们可以摆好开胃菜之类的东西。对，没错。克鲁顿面包？废话？然后我就可以……它们已经摆好了。
The appetizers are already out. Pop darts just in a row. Oh, Sean. Jen, thank you very, very much for doing that. Thank you. So nice to finally meet you. Jennifer Lawrence. This is lovely.
开胃菜已经摆好了。飞镖就排成一排。哦，肖恩。珍，非常非常感谢你这么做。谢谢。很高兴终于见到你。珍妮弗·劳伦斯。这太棒了。
Thank you for having me. All right, have a great rest of the day. Yeah. And have a great holiday. All right. Thank you. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, Jail. Bye.
谢谢邀请我。好的，祝你们剩下的一天过得愉快。好的。祝你们假期愉快。好的。谢谢。拜拜拜拜拜拜拜拜拜拜拜拜，杰尔。拜。
That's Jennifer Lawrence. That's what was supposed to be on the big stage at the Hollywood Bowl. I know. She got rained out. We got it. We got it. And yet we still, and then we had her, and then we, and then we just had her on here, which was amazing, which was great.
那是珍妮弗·劳伦斯。本来应该出现在好莱坞碗剧场的大舞台上的。我知道。她因为下雨取消了。我们拿到了。我们做到了。尽管如此，我们还是把她请到了这里，这太棒了，太棒了。
I know. And when I, when I found out that that was, so it was like after it got canceled, I was like, oh, it was Jennifer Lawrence. I was so excited. And then, and here she is. Now, did you guys, you guys did not know it was her. Not until after. No idea.
我知道。当我发现那是……也就是取消之后，我就想，哦，是珍妮弗·劳伦斯。我太兴奋了。然后，她就在这儿。现在，你们，你们当时不知道那是她。直到后来才知道。完全不知道。
No. No. No idea. And I knew, I knew it was going to be Jeremy Allen White a week beforehand. You did. Oh, right. Yeah. Yeah.
不。不。完全不知道。我知道，我提前一周就知道那是杰瑞米·艾伦·怀特。你知道。哦，对。对。对。
Because, right. Yeah. Because his agent mentioned it at something I was at. Oh, right. Right. But he, but, but, but, but, not his fault. Yeah, of course. But, yeah, that would have been, that would have been a, I can't believe it took us so long to have her on.
因为，对。对。因为他的经纪在我当时在的一个活动上提到了。哦，对。对。但他，但，但，但，不是他的错。对，当然。但是，对，那本该，那本该是，真不敢相信我们花了这么长时间才把她请来。
I know. She's one of those like, oh. On the peak, I know. She's sort of like. She was on my list, too. Yeah. I mean, she's fantastic. She has a lot of success quickly, but she handles it well.
我知道。她是那种，哦。在巅峰期，我知道。她有点像。她也在我的名单上。对。我的意思是，她太棒了。她很快就获得了巨大成功，但她处理得很好。
Very well. She's had so many great things. She's been so good and so many things. She's been in a movie every year for the last 20 years. I was looking on her thing. Is that a single year? Is that right, eh? Is that right, eh?
非常好。她有那么多出色的作品。她在很多作品里都表现得那么好。在过去的20年里，她每年都有一部电影。我刚才在看她的资料。真的是每年都有吗？对吗，诶？对吗，诶？
Yeah. And then, so die my love is out now. And then the Hunger Games, next Hunger Games thing, I think is coming out middle of next year. How about that? That's... You know it. Go ahead, Sean. You know what? Die My Love's coming out.
对。然后呢，《死吧，吾爱》现在上映了。接着是《饥饿游戏》，下一部《饥饿游戏》好像是在明年年中上映。怎么样？那是……你懂的。说吧，肖恩。你知道吗？《死吧，吾爱》要上映了。
Thank God, I mean, it's a good title. Thank God it was entitled. Bye, my love! That's exactly what I was going to do. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢天神，我的意思是，这是个好名字。谢天神它叫这个名字！这正是我要做的。Smartless。Smartless 是由贝内特·巴尔比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆贾夫100%手工精制而成的有机节目。Smartless。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。